UNUSUAL AGENDA THIS MORNING TO
SAY THE LEAST- UP AND- WE ARE
STILL WAITING FOR. MEMBERS TO
ARRIVE AT- A BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE HERE ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL MAY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I KNEW IF I TALKED
LONG ENOUGH SOMEBODY WOULD SHOW
UP. JUST TO GET ME TO STOP
TALKING. SO WELCOME OFFICIALLY
TO THE MAY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MEETING OF ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THREE ON
CLIMATE CRISIS RESOURCES ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION. WE WILL
BEGIN BY ESTABLISHING A QUORUM.
HELLO SENATE. FRIEDMAN MULLIN
PATTERSON RIVAS. SENATE
PRESIDENT QUORUM IS PRESENT
GREAT THANK YOU- I'LL PROCEED
NOW TO READ OUR OBLIGATORY
DIRECTIONS FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND TO MAKE SOME
BRIEF OPENING REMARKS AND THEN-
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF VOTES TO
TAKE AND PUBLIC COMMENT AND-
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH A SUMMARY OF
TODAY'S MEETING BUT I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO READ DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY. FOLLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION.
TODAY WE ARE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH TWO IN THE CAPITAL WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING WE ARE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH TWO AND CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP SIX
FEET OF SPACING. THERE ARE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. ALL RESTATE
WENT PUBLIC COMMENT BEGINS BUT
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK. THEY
SHOULD RAISE THEIR HANDS AND
I'LL ASK THEM TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. I DO ASK THAT THE
PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. EACH PERSON GIVING
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE A TOTAL OF ONE MINUTE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT IS COMPLETED OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING AT
ALL TIMES UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING. LIMITING THE
ELEVATOR USE TO ONLY TWO PEOPLE
AT A TIME. WITH RESPECT TO A
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT. IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET THAT
NUMBER IS. PUBLIC TOLL FREE.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO AGAIN THE NUMBER OF THE
PHONE NUMBER. IS. 877-692-8957
THERE'S NO CHARGE FOR THAT TO
CALL AND THE. TWO ZERO TWO IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL ASSIST YOU. WE DO
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. PLEASE SEND
YOUR WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
BUDGET SUB THREE USING THE
NUMERAL THREE BUDGET SUB THREE.
AT A. S. M. DOT CA DOT GOP
BUDGET BUDGET SUB THREE AT ASM.
DOT CA DOT GOV. AS CALIFORNIA
EMERGES FROM THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DISASTER THAT TO IS THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IT'S BECOMING
CLEAR THAT WE WILL IMMEDIATELY
FACE ADDITIONAL THREATS. SO FOR
EXAMPLE AS OF TODAY CALIFORNIA
HAS LESS THAN 2% OF ITS SNOW
PACK REMAINING AND A SEVERE
DROUGHT LOOMS OVER THE COMING
SUMMER MONTHS. CALIFORNIA IS
ALREADY REPORTED THIS
ASTOUNDING NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
WILDFIRE INCIDENTS THIS YEAR
THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF THIS
YEAR. AND OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND
ACRES HAVE ALREADY BURNED IN
THE STATE. WE ARE BRACING FOR
ANOTHER YEAR OF HARSH AND
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES POWER
DISRUPTIONS AND SMOKE FILLED
AIR. THE STRONG CALIFORNIA
COMEBACK ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLANS OF
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE PROVIDED
RESOURCES FOR US TO PREPARE FOR
THE COMING CHALLENGE. THESE
FUNDS ALSO ALLOW US TO FINALLY
BE PROACTIVE ON THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. WE CAN INVEST IN
CLIMATE RESILIENCY INCLUDING
ADAPTATION PLANNING AND
PROJECTS AND OPEN SPACE. WE CAN
IMPROVE OUR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM ESPECIALLY FOR OPTIONS
THAT REDUCE VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED LIKE TRANSIT AND
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION. WE CAN
BUILD UPON OUR CLEAN ENERGY
SYSTEMS CONTINUE OUR WORLD
LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN VEHICLE
INNOVATION AND ADVANCES TO
AGRICULTURE. AND WE CAN MAKE
INVESTMENTS TO BRIDGE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE SO THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
BROADBAND. BUT WE ONLY HAVE
TWENTY MORE DAYS UNTIL JUNE
FIFTEENTH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
BUDGET DEADLINE DOES NOT GIVE
US ENOUGH TIME TO- I TRULY
THOUGHT FULLY ADDRESS ALL OF
THESE ISSUES THE AGENDA TODAY
AND THE SUBCOMMITTEE. CONTAINS
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
ACTION ITEMS WHICH ARE INTENDED
TO ALLOW THE SUB COMMITTEE TO
CLOSE DOWN FOR THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND ADVANCE THE BUDGET
DISCUSSION FORWARD. YOU WILL
NOTICE THAT FOR MANY OF THE
LARGER ITEMS AND PACKAGES THE
STAFF OF MAN ABSTRACT PROPOSED
ACTION TO ADVANCE. THE
CONVERSATION. WE PLAN TO WORK
WITH OUR FRIENDS IN THE SENATE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS ON
ITEMS FOR BOTH THE JUNE
FIFTEENTH BUDGET AND BEYOND.
LIKE THE WILDFIRE PACKAGE
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE WILL BRING
THOSE AGREEMENTS BACK TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. WHEN THE
APPROPRIATE TIME OCCURS. I WILL
BE ASKING FOR SOME MOTIONS TO
DISPENSE WITH THE VERY LARGE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR. I'VE ASKED
STAFF TO ORGANIZE THE ISSUES
AND TO MOTIONS TO EXPEDITE THIS
ACTION. THEY ARE LENGTHY THE-
NUMERICAL CHARACTERS FOR A
CATEGORIES ARE CARP A QUITE
LARGE. AND OF COURSE WE WILL
AGAIN HEAR PUBLIC COMMENT TO
INFORM THE CONVERSATION AS WE
PROGRESS TO OUR JUNE SECOND
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE HEARING.
BUT BEFORE WE BEGIN I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE HARD WORK OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THEIR STAFF EACH OF YOU HAS
PROVIDED A THOUGHTFUL
PERSPECTIVE ON THE CHALLENGES
FACING THE STATE IN OUR POWER.
IN OUR POLICY AREA. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS IDEAS
AND COMMITMENT THAT YOU ALL
BRING TO THE HEARINGS. I LOOK
FORWARD TO TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WHEN I BELIEVE THE HEALTH
RESTRICTIONS WILL EASE AND
ALLOW US TO MEET MORE REGULARLY
AND WITH MORE FOCUS. I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE DEDICATED
STAFF THAT SUPPORT OUR MEMBERS
BOTH YOUR STAFF MY CHIEF OF
STAFF GUY STRONG. AND KIRSTEN
CORPORATE K. FROM THE
REPUBLICAN POLICY OFFICE AND OF
COURSE GENEVIEVE SHY CHRISTIAN
AND SUSAN FROM OUR BUDGET TEAM.
BOTH CURRENT HADN'T IMMEDIATELY
PASSED WELL A PAST HOLLAND JUST
PASSED PA YESTERDAY- OB BUT I
ALSO WANT TO PAUSE TO RECOGNIZE
SOME OF THE UNSEEN FACES THAT
MAKE THESE HEARINGS HAPPEN THE
LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER STAFF
THAT MAKE THE VIRTUAL WITNESSES
HAPPEN IS ALL VERY COMPLICATED.
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS THAT
HAVE BEEN HERE IN PERSON FOR
EVERY HEARING THE A. T. AND T.
OPERATOR STAFF THAT- LABORS IN
THE ETHER UP ABOVE US- AND THAT
FACILITATES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC COMMENT. MARCO RODRIGUEZ
AND IRENE BELARUS THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE SECRETARIES TO
TROUBLE SHOOT EVERY VIRTUAL
PANELISTS FOR EVERY BUDGET
HEARING AND MONITOR EVERY
PUBLIC COMMENT PHONE LINE.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE ALL
ESSENTIAL AND MANY OF THEM
LABOR BEHIND THE SCENES DURING
THE PANDEMIC TO MAKE THIS
PROCESS POSSIBLE. I DO WANT TO
OBSERVE- THAT WE HAVE ON
FOLDING SADLY- IN THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE ANOTHER GUN RELATED.
TRAGEDY WE DON'T KNOW THE FULL
EXTENT OF THE FATALITIES IN THE
AND THE INJURIES- BUT- I DIDN'T
WANNA LET THE OPPORTUNITY PASS
A- WITHOUT- OBSERVING THAT THIS
IS UNFOLDING AT THIS VERY
MOMENT AND WE WANT TO SEND OUR-
CONDOLENCES AND LOVE IN
CONCERNS TO- OF THE- OF VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. WITH THAT
DOES ANY OTHER MEMBER HAVE
COMMENTS- THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE
TO MAKE. SURE SURE MISTER
BENNETT I HAVE A FEW COMMENTS
ABOUT SOME OF THE ITEMS BUT I
DON'T KNOW. BEING MY FIRST TIME
THROUGH THIS PROCESS IS IT
BETTER TO WAIT UNTIL THOSE
ITEMS COME UP OR WE NOT GONNA
BE TAKING COMMENTS DURING THE
ITEMS YOU UP AND MAKE THE
COMMENTS NOW WHAT WHAT WHAT'S
YOUR PROJECT YOU HAVE COMMENTS
NOW WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE
TIME TO. MAKE THEM. GREAT AND
RIVAS WILL FOLLOW. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- ITEM- THIRTY
FIVE WHICH IS ON PAGE TWENTY
FOUR- TYING THE- FREE- INCREASE
ON THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT ON
THE OIL SPILL. SPILL PREVENTION
FUND. I'M JUST HAPPY TO SEE.
THE SHIFT IN THE FISCAL
PLANNING BY- ADDING THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX ENDED
THAT. IT'S HELPFUL BECAUSE IT
WILL GIVE CERTAINTY TO
EVERYBODY THEY KNOW WHERE
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE GOING
WITH THAT- AND- WE CAN ALL PLAN
BETTER AND IT CERTAINLY. JUST
MAKES MORE SENSE FOR THE FISCAL
HEALTH OF- THE GOVERNMENT OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THAT BUILT
IN THERE SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
ON ITEM THIRTY I MEAN ITEM
SEVENTY THREE- I WOULD. WHICH
IS PAGE FORTY FOUR I JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT. THERE'S A THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR CAL
RECYCLE. IN IT. I'VE REFERRED
TO IT BEFORE BUT I THINK IT'S
SORT OF A SLOW MOVING- CRISIS
THAT'S- GOING TO REALLY- BLOW
UP ON US- POTENTIALLY AND THAT
IS RECYCLING. THE WHOLE
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
INDUSTRY- IT HAS FALLEN APART.
AS A RESULT OF THOSE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES SORT OF IN
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY. AND WE NEED
TO OF. THIS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO TRY TO ATTRACT NEW
BUSINESSES. THAT WANT TO. COME
UP WITH NEW IDEAS ON HOW TO
RECYCLE HERE- IN CALIFORNIA-
SO- REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND
I. CERTAINLY HOPE- AND PASS ON
TO THE TO THE CHAIR OF HOPE
THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO PRESERVE
THAT FUNDING IN BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS ESPECIALLY GO
FORWARD. AND THEN I. WOULD ALSO
JUST END HERE THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME SERVING- ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE IT'S OUR LAST DAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU ARE YOU
MISTER CHAIR- FOR HOW YOU RUN
THESE- COMMITTEE MEETING SEVEN
PER SHARE THAT- AND I THINK YOU
BRING- AN APPROPRIATE SORT OF
PERSONALITY OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT PLEASANTNESS AT THE SAME
TIME. THAT'S A RARE THING HAVE
HAPPENED. AND ALSO LIKE TO
THANK CHRISTIAN A GENEVIEVE AND
SHY- FOR YOUR INNER. WITH MY
STAFF AND IN THE HARD WORK IN
GETTING ALL OF THIS- ORGANIZED
WORKSHOPS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MS RIVAS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I HAD A COMMENT
ON ISSUE THIRTY FOUR-
SPECIFICALLY ON THE- PUBLIC
RECREATION FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. OF YOU KNOW I'M
SUPPORTING THIS ITEM TODAY- BUT
I DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE TO SEE-
A SPECIFIC SET ASIDE- FOR GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS AS THIS HEADS TO
THE FULL. BUDGET COMMITTEE YOU
KNOW I KNOW THAT. I APPRECIATE
AND I SUPPORT MORE ACCESS TO
PARKS IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES- BUT SOME
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
UNFORTUNATELY- EITHER BECAUSE
OF DENSITY WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF SPACE. TO PUT A PARKIN OR
LIKE LOS ANGELES. THAT LAND IS
VERY EXPENSIVE HEY AND SO- I
SEE AN OPPORTUNITY TO USE-
EXISTING PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE-
AND SITES LIKE SCHOOLS. TO PUT
IN MORE GREEN SPACE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES- BUT I ALSO LIKE TO
THANK OUR CHAIR AND THE BUDGET
STAFF AND EVERYONE THAT'S BEEN
WORKING SO HARD- TO GET THIS
BUDGET OF COMPLETE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE. ALL OF YOUR TIME SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WILL. MISTER MON JUST
VERY BRIEFLY AT ANOTHER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE STAFF
AND NOT COLLEAGUES FOR A
PRODUCTIVE THIS SESSION UNDER-
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES WITH
THE COVERED RESTRICTIONS BUT UP
VERY MUCH INTEREST IN THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE ISSUES AS
YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN A PUSHING UP
BOND ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES-
EDUARDO GARCIA- ON- THE CLIMATE%
RESILIENCY AND WILDFIRE ISSUES
MORE BROADLY SO LOOKING FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THAT DISCUSSION
BUT ALSO HOPEFUL THAT WITHIN
THIS BUDGET CYCLE WE MAY ABLE
TO DO MAY BE ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING CONSTRUCTIVE WITH
THEIR SENATE COLLEAGUES. ON
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND THOSE
OTHER ISSUES SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO A CONTINUING CONVERSATION-
NATALIE BEFORE- JUNE FIFTEENTH
PERHAPS AFTER AND THE TRAILER
BILL CAPACITY WE'LL SEE HOW THE
CONVERSATION UNFOLDS BUT AGAIN
GRATEFUL- FOR THE CHURCH
LEADERSHIP AND- THANK YOU TO
THE STAFF AS WELL. THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE A SERIES OF FAST SIX
VOTES THAT ALL ASK FOR AND I
WILL RECITE THESE SLOWLY
BECAUSE THERE ARE AN AWFUL LOT
OF NUMBERS- AND STAFF IS GOING
TO FOLLOW ALONG AND MAKE SURE
THAT I GET IT RIGHT AND IF I
MESS UP THEN- THEY'RE GONNA.
LIKE WAVE FLAGS OR THROW THINGS
AT ME- SO THE FIRST VOTE SAID
THAT I WOULD REQUEST A MOTION
ON- IS ON ITEMS ONE. THREE
THREE FIVE. EIGHT THREE
THIRTEEN. 1-719-212-2520 SEVEN
TO THIRTY. THIRTY THREE THIRTY
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT FORTY ONE.
FORTY THREE TO FORTY SIX. FIFTY
ONE TO FIFTY THREE. FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE TO SIXTY
TWO. SIXTY FIVE. SIXTY SEVEN TO
SEVENTY ONE. SEVENTY FOUR TO
SEVENTY EIGHT. EIGHTY ONE TO
EIGHTY FOUR. EIGHTY SIX. EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHTY NINE. NINETY FIVE
TO NINETY EIGHT. ONE A ONE TO
ONE OH EIGHT. ONE TEN TO ONE OH
THREE ONE TWENTY FIVE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT TO ONE THIRTY
SEVEN ONE THIRTY NINE ONE FORTY
TWO AND ONE FORTY SEVEN I KNOW
SOME OF THAT SOUNDED LIKE
BASKETBALL SCORES AND TONIGHT.
MESS UP. ONE TEN TO ONE TWENTY
THREE. MOTION TO APPROVE. SO
JUST TO BE CLEAR ONE TEN ONE
TWENTY THREE IS TO BE INCLUDED
IN THAT IN THAT MOTION WE HAVE
A MOTION AND SECOND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET'S PROCEED TO
VOTE. HELLO HI. SENATE HI
FRIEDMAN MULLIN. PATTERSON
RIVAS. SMITH HI. SIX ZERO THANK
YOU- I WOULD NEXT ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEMS.
FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY TWENTY
SIX THIRTY ONE THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR TO THIRTY SIX FORTY
FORTY TWO FORTY SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT FIFTY FOUR FIFTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR SIXTY SIX SEVENTY TO
EIGHTY FIVE NINETY NINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR ONE TWENTY SIX ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. AND ONE THIRTY
EIGHT DO I HAVE A MOTION. SO
MOVED. THANK YOU THERE'S A
MOTION AND A SECOND LET'S HAVE
A ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE WELL I
SENATE HI FRIEDMAN RIGHT. WHAT
PATTERSON RIVAS HI SMITH NO.
FIVE ONE. THANK YOU THAT PASSES.
OUR NEXT VOTE TO I'D LIKE TO
ASK FOR A MOTION ON ITEMS.
714-409-5070. THREE SEVENTY
NINE EIGHTY EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
THREE NINETY FOUR ONE HUNDRED
ONE OH NINE AND. ONE FORTY
THREE TO ONE FORTY SIX DURING
OUR MOTION. SO MOVED THAT THANK
YOU THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND
MAY WE HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE
PLEASE HELLO HI SENATE HI
FRIEDMAN. MULLIN- PATTERSON
RIVAS HI SMITH. FIVE ZERO NEXT
FOR ISSUE THIRTY NINE WE ARE
TAKING TO VOTES THE FIRST VOTE
WOULD BE TO APPROVE ALL ITEMS
EXCEPT FOR OCEANIA DUNES
LIFEGUARD TOWER PISMO BEACH
KIOSK AND LESS SAGE BRIDGE IS
THERE A MOTION SOME OF. SECOND
THANK YOU. LET'S HAVE A ROLL
CALL VOTE PLEASE HELLO HI
SENATE HI FRIEDMAN. MULLIN
PATTERSON RIVAS HI SMITH HI.
SIX ZERO. THANK YOU THAT PASSES.
NEXT DO I HEAR A MOTION TO
APPROVE UNDER ISSUE THIRTY NINE
ITEMS THE FOLLOWING ITEMS- CNO
JUNE'S LIFEGUARD TOWER PISMO
BEACH KIOSK AND LIZ SAGE BRIDGE.
HELLO. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. A ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE
WELL HI SENATE HI FRIEDMAN.
MULLIN PATTERSON RIVAS HI SMITH
NO. FIVE ONE THAT PASSES THANK
YOU AND FINALLY ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWO THE RECOMMENDATION. IS TO
DEFER BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO APPROVE
ISSUE TO. SO MOVED. THANK YOU
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND
ROUND WE WILL NOW HAVE A ROLL
CALL VOTE WELL I SENATE HI.
FRIEDMAN MULLIN PATTERSON.
RIVAS. SIX ZERO THANK YOU THAT
CONCLUDES THE VOTING PORTION OF
FOR OUR AGENDA. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK PLEASE LET
ME KNOW NOW AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE- RAISE
YOUR HAND IF YOU. LIKE TO GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE ROOM I'M
SAYING I WANT SO WE WILL MOVE
ON NOW- TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
GET PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE
PHONE OPERATOR YOU READY. YES
SIR I'M READY ALL RIGHT IT'S
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE- LET ME
AGAIN REPEAT THE PHONE NUMBER
TO CONNECT FOR THOSE WHO MAY
NOT OF HEARD IT EARLIER- IT
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET BUT THE PHONE NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
THAT'S TOLL FREE AGAIN IT'S.
877-692-8957 WITH THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE OF ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. OPERATOR WOULD YOU BEGIN-
ENQUIRING WHO MADE AMONG THOSE
WHO MAY WISH TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT. GLAD TO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE CURRENTLY HAVE THIRTY
ONE IN Q. WILL START WITH MY
NUMBER TWENTY LIKE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. SH GOOD
MORNING CARE LUMEN MEMBERS AND
STAFF THE CENTER FOR FOOD AT
TIFFANY MOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE FOR FOOD SAFETY- WE LIKE
TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY AND- FOR
ITS SUPPORT OF A TRANSITION TO
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
INCLUDING FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR UNDERSERVED
FARMERS FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM
HEALTHY SOILS AND A STATEWIDE
PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
AS WELL AS INVESTMENTS IN
POLLINATOR HABITAT. WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE BUDGET LANGUAGE
TO ENSURE ENHANCED PESTICIDES
AIR MONITORING WILL BE LINKED
OVERSIGHT ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS-
C. CFS POSES ANY FUNDING FOR
GERRY DIED AFTER WHICH CLICK
WHILE DOING NOTHING TO REDUCE
AIR AND WATER POLLUTION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY ARE OFTEN LOCATED FINALLY
WE HOPE THE FINAL BUDGET
INCLUDES A CHEER PESTICIDE
MIDDLE T. TO FIND MORE
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
RESOURCES AND COMMUNITY
PROTECTIONS THANK YOU AGAIN SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND I
SHOULD HAVE WROTE REMINDED
FOLKS. THAT WE'RE LIMITING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. TWO ONE
MINUTE TO A TOTAL OF ONE MINUTE.
NEXT SPEAKER PLACE. BY TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXACT DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FIVE TRANSIT UMBRELLA AGENCIES
ACROSS OUR STATE SPEAKING TODAY
ON ISSUES 1-793-991-0140 FOUR
AND WHAT FORTY SIX. TOGETHER
THESE ISSUES ENCOMPASS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS FOR
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION A CAP AND
TRADE THE CALIFORNIA COME BACK
PLAN IS REALLY TO
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND STATUTORY RELIEF FOR
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT AGENCIES.
GIVEN THE BREADTH OF ISSUES ALL
SPEAK GENERALLY EMPHASIZED THAT
WHAT CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE NO LONGER IN THE%
DEATHS OF CRISIS IS STILL VERY
MUCH- NEEDING SUPPORT TO RETURN
TO PRE PANDEMIC SERVICE LEVELS
RIDERSHIP AND REVENUES. I DO
NOTE THAT WE HAVE A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY BRING PUBLIC
TRANSIT BACK FROM THE PANDEMIC
STRONGER CLEANER MORE EQUITABLE
THAN BEFORE I AM WITH THAT I DO
WANT TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE FULL SUITE OF INVESTMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IN THE
ISSUES IDENTIFIED. AND URGE YOU
TO ADVANCE IN TODAY- WITHIN
THOSE INVESTMENTS THE TITLE
THAT YOU MAINTAIN THE SPECIFIC
SUPPORT TO TRANSIT AGENCIES
THAT FUND THEIR TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY
WELCOME VOICE HER FULL SUPPORT
FOR THE STATURE RELIEF MEASURES
PROPOSED. BY THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ATTEND THOSE MEASURES TO TACKLE
YOUR TWENTY THREE TWENTY GROW.
UP PLEASE IF WE CAN. THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. ONE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. SH
THE MORNING AFTER BERMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING FOR THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
FISHING GAME MORE THAN
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION WERE HEARTENED BY
THE INVESTMENT PROPOSED FOR
CDFW AND IT WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION CORPS IN SUPPORT
THE DROUGHT PACKAGES PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR ECOSYSTEM HONORING
OF CHURCH METROPCS OVERTIME AND
EQUIPMENT FOR WILDLIFE OFFICERS
AND PRINT EXPERTS. AND NOTABLY
THE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
FOR WCB TO IMPROVE AND
CONSTRUCT WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
CANNOT SUPPORT THE PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE OPC AN
ELEVEN AND A HALF MILLION FOR
STATE PARKS FOR COASTAL WETLAND
RESTORATION AND SEALABLE RIDE
THAT OCCASION. AND WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF THE
FINAL FUNDING TO COMPLETE THE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM TRAFFIC ON
THAT FINALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS I WANT TO LIFT UP THE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR ASK NESTED WITHIN THE
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
CHAMPION I ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN ON YOUR COMMITTEE. TO
ENSURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL HISTORICAL AND
DOMINANT THE RESOURCES AGENCY
RECEIVED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. AND THE FINAL
BUDGET THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. MY THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THANK YOU TERRIBLY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NIKITA
CROWDY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
AGENDA FAIRLY EXTENSIVE OF
ELEVEN MY COMMENT TO JUST A FEW
ISSUES ON THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET AS YOU
NEGOTIATE A FINAL ALLOCATIONS
WE ASK THAT YOU INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE TRANSPORTATION
EQUITY PROJECT A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WILL ENSURE
THAT AT LEAST 50% OF THE SEE IF
YOU CAN TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
INVESTMENTS ARE LOCATED AND
BENEFIT LOW INCOME HISPANIC
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO ASK THAT
YOU DO NOT TAKE EIGHTY EIGHT
RAPPER THE SHOPKEEPER YOUR IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE SEND THE
pNINETEENTH IN UPCOMING START
THAT QUICKLY TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENT GOING FORWARD
UNSUSTAINABLE PATH MANAGEMENT
IN THE AGRICULTURE BUDGET WE
SUPPORT THE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED IN THE REVISED
FOR CDFA FARM TO SCHOOL
PROGRAM. WE ALSO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT HEARING AND UPDATING
THE PETRIFIED MELFI TO THE
SENSE THAT THE INCENTIVIZE THE
USE OF THE NOT DANGEROUS
PESTICIDES BUT IN THE MEANTIME
WE SUPPORT MANY OF THE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSED INVESTMENT TO
TRANSITION TO TAKE A PATH
MANAGEMENT INCLUDING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR BECAUSE
NOTIFICATION NETWORK ANY
RECOMMENDATION THAT BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO LINK TO PACIFY
THEIR MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT
WITH ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
WHAT'S MISSING FROM THE PLANET
FUNDING FOR DIRECT COMMUNITY
PROTECTIONS AND WE STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO INCLUDE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY
SUPPORT FIND A PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO THE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA AT THE GREATEST RISK
OF HARM COMPATIBLE THANK YOU. I
THINK I'LL STOP THERE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. TO COMMENT
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LATER FORTY LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN TO ROUTES
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE AND ONE OF ITS
PROGRAMS WOULD THE CHANGE
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ISSUE SEVENTY NINE SPECIFICALLY
THE HEALTHY STORES
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAMS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT SUBCOMMITTEE
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THIS
PROGRAM CHAMPION BY FAMILY
MEMBER TEAM WHICH RECENTLY
CONCLUDED ITS SUCCESSFUL FIRST
ROUND OF FUNDING IN FORTY OF
THE FIFTY COUNTY. THIS TWENTY
MILLION WILL SUPPORT EXPANDING
THE PROGRAM'S REACH EVEN MORE
PARTS OF THE STATE'S PORTING
CORNER STORE OWNERS EMERGENCY
FOOD INFRASTRUCTURE AND LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS INTO
DESERT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY BY COMMENT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THE MORE INSURED MEMBERS
DANCE HALLS ON BEHALF OF
CONCERT THERE ARE EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORTER GOVERNOR
NUISANCE PROPOSED BUDGET WHICH
PROPOSES NEARLY ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS TO ADVANCE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES NUMBER
STRUCTURE. CRITICAL INCIDENT
PROGRAMS LIKE H. THAT HAVE BEEN
WITHOUT FUNDING FOR OVER
EIGHTEEN MONTHS MANY TIMES THAT
THE ESSENCE FOR THIS PROJECT.
ANY BILLION FUNDING PROGRAMS
JEOPARDIZE OUR TRANSACTIONS AS
YOU GAIN SOME BOXING WORLD TO
MANUFACTURERS MEANS MORE
POLLUTION OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. WHAT
WE NINETEEN BALLOTS FUNDING
CERTAIN BEING ERIC'S MANDATE
REQUIRING. TRAILER BILL WHICH
UNDERGONE. SIGNAL TO THE
INDUSTRY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY TWENTY YEAR LOW IS NOW UP.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS ARE
BACK IN ARKANSAS REPRESENTING
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORKING CARPETS
I CONSTITUTE REGARDING ISSUE
EIGHTY SEVEN CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE FIRST I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND SHARE OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE ASSEMBLY
STRONG COMMITMENT. TO A
SUSTAINABLE AND RESILIENT
AGRICULTURE ECONOMY AS NOTED IN
YOUR AGENDA TODAY WE SUPPORT
THE HEALTHY SOILS INVESTMENT OF
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
LIVESTOCK METHANE REDUCTION AND
AFTER THAT ALL THE FUNDING GO
TOWARD THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. REGARDING
ISSUE NINETY ONE THE WATER
RSILIENCY AND TRACK PACKAGE WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR SUPPOSED
WILL TO FUND THE STATE WATER
EFFICIENCY ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM
AT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND THE MARGIN BACK INVESTMENTS
AND STATE BACKED HOWEVER WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE FAA HAS
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
GRANTS FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO LANDOWNERS. FORCING MY
COMPLIANCE REGARDING ISSUE
EIGHTY NINE CLIMATE RESILIENCY
WE ASKED OF THE ASSEMBLY NEAR
THE SENATE'S INCLUSION OF
FUNDING TO THE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION BUT
OUR FARMLAND PROTECTION PROGRAM
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT WAYS
TO MAXIMIZE THE AGRICULTURE
ECONOMY DEVELOPING TO HELP
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE BY
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND REMOVING CARBON
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. IF YOU THE
PERMANENT CONSERVATION OF
AGRICULTURAL LANDS REGARDING
ISSUE SEVENTY NINE SPECIFICALLY
THE SENIOR NUTRITION PIECE OF
CDFA HEALTHY RESILIENT
EQUITABLE FOOD SYSTEM PROPOSAL
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERFACE
AVAILABLE THROUGH COLLABORATIVE
AND THAT INNOVATIVE HEALTH
SOLUTIONS WELL WE APPRECIATE
THE PROPOSAL A FIFTY FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THE SENIOR FARMERS MARKET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MY
THIRTY SIX YEAR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MORNING TRIP CAN MEMBERS
YOU'RE TIRED STAFF- THIS IS
STEVE MEYERS ON BEHALF OF STATE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE MAINTENANCE
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
LAND TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AND FUN THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION IN REFERENCE
TO ISSUES EIGHTY NINE. NINETY
ONE AND NINETY TWO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE ASSEMBLY
CONSIDERATION OF MATCHING
FUNDING AMOUNTS WITH THE SENATE
PLAN. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
OVERALL FUNDING AMOUNTS IN THE
SENATE PLANS FOR THE PACKAGES
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE BUDGET COMMITTEES TO
ENSURE THE UNPRECEDENTED AND
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS ARE
TARGETED TO EFFECTIVELY MEET
THE URGENT CLIMATE AND
CONSERVATION. NEEDS OF THE
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- MARC A PRAYER
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SAID TO
CLIENTS- ON ISSUE FORTY FISCAL
STABILITY FOR BOATING PROGRAMS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
CLEMENTE WE SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S- BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
SUSPEND FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
BEACH RESTORATION. GRANT
PROGRAMS AND RESTORE THAT
FUNDING- IN THE ADOPTED TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO STATE- BUDGET
THE ISSUE IS PUBLIC SAFETY SAN
CLEMENTE'S MARINE SAFETY
HEADQUARTERS ARE AT RISK
FURTHER SOME BEACH ACCESS
POINTS HAVE HAD TO CLOSE DUE TO
A ROSHEN CREATING UNSAFE ACCESS
TO CERTAIN AREAS OF THE BEACH.
ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES
REGARDING ISSUE SEVENTY THREE
WE WISH TO ALIGN OURSELVES WITH
THE MAY TWENTY FOUR LETTER
SIGNED BY MORE THAN FORTY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE SOLID
WASTE ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL A FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CAL RECYCLE FOR
AGAIN MAKE WASTE RECYCLING.
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IN ADDITION WE REQUEST
THIS THE- IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
INCREASE THIS AMOUNT TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE- THE- ALLOCATION OF
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU SHERMAN WOMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TYLER ABRAMS REPRESENTING TREAT
PEOPLE WE APPRECIATE THE MAY
REVISED FUNDING URBAN GREENING
PROGRAM AND TRANSFORM IT CRIME
COMMUNITIES AT APPROPRIATE
LEVELS YOU PROGRAMS PROVIDE
MULTI BENEFITS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND SUPPORT NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS HOWEVER WE ARE
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
THE LAKLAND BASS MICROPROSE BY
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT COULD
HELP BUYERS URBAN COMMUNITY
FORESTRY PROGRAM. THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IS THE
PRIMARY SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED PROJECTS FOR
COMBATING EXTREME HEAT TREE
PLANTING AND A PRIORITY FOR
NONPROFITS INCLUDING TREAT
PEOPLE THROUGH HE CAUSED MORE
DEATHS IN THE U. S. THAN ALL
OTHER WEATHER RELATED CAUSES
COMBINED AND EVEN MORE ALARMING
FACT HOWEVER IS THAT. THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
PLACE IN THE WORLD WHERE HE GOT.
THAT OCCUR DURING WINTER MONTHS.
A COMPREHENSIVE TO COMBAT A
CRIME. SHOULD BEGIN THE
INTEGRATING. FOR LIKE
HEALTHCARE ORANGE. CORSICA I
THOUGHT WE URGE YOU JOIN
MEMBERS CRISTINA GARCIA LORENA
GONZALEZ AUTUMN BURKE KEVIN
MCCARTY ASH KALRA AND ELOISE
GOMEZ REYES AND SUPPORTING THE
PROPOSAL FOR OPEN GREENING.
CYCLICAL SPEAKING EQUAL FUNDING
FOR URBAN. FORESTRY AT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR THIS IS MAHDI AL
RAJABI HAVE A CALIFORNIA
RELEASED ME I WANT TO CONCUR
WITH THREE PEOPLE AND- WE WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR UPLIFTING A
REINFORCING URBAN GREENING
TODAY'S AGENDA WE APPRECIATE
THAT INVESTMENTS MUST BE MADE
AND REPLANTING TREES AND
INCLUDING A RECORD WE ALSO WANT
TO THANK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA FOR CHAMPION A
PROPOSAL TO INVEST FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE YEAR AND
CARSHARING GREEN PROGRAMS AND
USE THAT SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY THAT JOINT HEARING
THAT EFFORT THIS IS FURTHER
SUPPORTED IN A LETTER SIGNED BY
OVER A HUNDRED. COMMUNITY BASED
GROUPS AND SMALL BUSINESSES
INCLUDING LA CONSERVATION CORPS
SAN FRANCISCO FRIENDS OF THE
URBAN POOREST ELEVATE. CLTV LOS
ANGELES BEAUTIFICATION TEAM AND
AT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR RESOURCE CONSERVATION
DISTRICT WE ARE DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED A RUN
YOU DOLLARS IN THE MAIN
REQUESTED SUPPORT SUCH EFFORTS
YOU CALPERS OUR MEMBERSHIP
PROGRAM WE LOOK FORWARD. TO
WORKING WITH THE- LEGISLATURE-
FUND BOTH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI ONE OF THEM YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT A BUNCH- FIRST OFF ON
ISSUE THIRTY SIX ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR-
OUTDOOR ACCESS FOR ALL WE'D
LIKE TO SUPPORT THAT- ISSUE
AREA- ARE NOT ISSUES RELATED TO
URBAN FORESTRY WILL WANT TO
ALIGN OURSELVES. WITH THE
COMMENTS- THAT SHE PEOPLE AND
CALIFORNIA RELIEF MADE ON
ISSUES RELATED TO THE DROUGHT-
WE WOULD LIKE- WE SENT A LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE RELATED- TWO
THOUSAND EMPLOYMENT PATIENTS
RELATED TO OVERSIGHT HEARING
THAT AND- AREAS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE HAVE A DIRECT
IMPACT ON IMPORTANT BUT HAVE
ATTACKED ALONG THE SIX
LIGHTWEIGHT. YOU RECOMMEND THEY
THE IMPLEMENTATION- OF THE
FOLLOWING PRACTICES OF OUR
PRACTICES WELL BOYS MINIMUM AND
MINIMIZE AND MITIGATE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF DROUGHT
WILL HAVE ON MANY- MILLIONS OF
BIRDS ACROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU FOR. SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
TWENTY FOUR YEAR LINE OF HELP.
GOOD MORNING NATALIE NOT GOING
TO HAVE A COMMUNITY MAJOR
CONNECTION NATURE FOR ALL
ELECTRIC BURKE EXPECTED SUPPORT
FOR THE MONEY FOR CONSERVANCY
IS THE ONE AREA HOWEVER I WOULD
LIKE TO BE FUNDING FOR INSTANCE
PARK NEAR THE BASE WORKSHOPS
ARE WORKFORCE TRAINIG AND
CAREER PATHWAYS PROGRAM AND IF
I COMMUNITY ACTION PROGRAM THAT
COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
WITH THE CENTER IF. YOU CAN
ACCESS GRANT PROGRAM SEKALI ON
BEHALF OF CALVINISTIC PARK
NOTATION OVERALL WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENT TO A STATE PARK
MAINTENANCE FACILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA ACT WITH THEM THAT
INCLUDES FOR DOING IT WE DO
HOWEVER- URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
FUNDING STATE PARK COMMENT THE
RECENTLY DEVELOPED ALL RIGHT
ACTIVATION STRATEGY AND FOR
SEARCH OF THE STATE ON LAND.
ALL THESE IS ARE CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING STATE PARK
PROPERTIES AND OF CLIMATE
CHANGE EXPAND OUR ABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO ACT WITHIN TWO
AFTER ANY PROCEDURE CAN FUNDING
ABOUT OUTLINED IN THE MAYBE.
FIVE THANK YOU. WHY DID THREE
YEAR LINE IS NOW. THE MORE MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WE COME DINNER-
WITH THE TRUCK REPORT LAND. WE
VERY MUCH THE GUY COULD FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
URBAN GREENING PROGRAM FOR ALL
THE REASONS REGARDING HER-
DEADLY HEAT IS HERE AND IT'S
GONNA GET WORSE- WELL BEEF
CAN'T WAIT. PASSED JUNE
FIFTEENTH. PLEASE CONSIDER
THAT. AND I ALSO WANT TO BRING
UP- ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS IS
CRAP I THANK SCHOOLYARDS GREEN
SCHOOLYARDS. POSSIBLE PLANS
BEEN DOING THAT THE NEW YORK
CITY FOR MANY YEARS. WE'VE
INCREASED THE CAP MINUTE WALK
ACCESSIBLE FOUR POINT ONE
MILLION PEOPLE BY GREENING
SCHOOLYARDS THERE AND ALSO
PROVIDE THE KEY AND EXPLAIN
FLOOD PROTECTION. THAT GREEN
SPACES DO- ODDBALLS GREENING
SCHOOLYARD BUT NOT- INCLUDE AN
ACQUISITION THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS MENTIONED. THIS IS
A GREAT FRONT HERE FOR US TO
REALLY MAKE IT DANCE AND
GREENING OUR MOST- IMPROV
THERE'S AND- PARK FOR
COMMUNITY- SO LET'S WORK ON
THAT TOGETHER. I THANK VERY
MUCH. FOR YOUR ARE COMMON IN
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REMEMBER SOME GREAT HELPS FISH
CONSERVATION PROGRAMSMANAGER
WITH OCEAN CONSERVANCY WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED PLAN INVESTMENTS IN
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL TO
PLAY A COORDINATING ROLE IN
PROTECTING RESTORING AND
CREATING AN ADDITIONAL TEN
THOUSAND ACRES OF COASTAL
WETLANDS BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
INCLUSION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION OVER TWO YEARS PROVIDES
CRITICAL FUNDING TO ADVANCE
COASTAL WETLANDS RESTORATION
CRITICAL FOR PROTECTING AGAINST
SEA LEVEL RISE ALONG WITH.
URGENT CALL BENEFITS- FROM
BIODIVERSITY PROTECTION CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IN PUBLIC ACCESS
WE BELIEVE THAT OBESITY IS THE
RIGHT STATE ANYTHING JUST OVER
THE STRATEGY SO THAT HIGHEST
COASTAL RESILIENCE WET PLAN
WETLANDS RESTORATION PROJECTS
ARE PRIORITIZED BUSHING
INSURGENCY ALSO URGES YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE STATE PARK SEA LEVEL
RISE ADAPTATION. STRATEGY AND
FINALLY WE THINK THE SENATE
PROPOSING AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION FOR THE COOK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
SEA LEVEL RISE- ASSISTANCE
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS BECAUSE FOR COMBAT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY WE SUPPORT
MANY ASPECTS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE PROPOSAL INCLUDING
INCREASED FUNDING FOR CDFW
CUTTING THE GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVE CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR
ACCESS FOR ALL AND DEEP SEA
LEVEL RISE STRATEGY CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS THE DROUGHT
SPENDING PROPOSAL AND NUMEROUS
OTHER PRIOR EVEN GOOD ENOUGH
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE. WITH
REGARD TO ITEM EIGHTY NINE
CLIMATE RESILIENT PACKAGE WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE ASSEMBLY
WILL DISCUSS THE POTENTIAL OF
INCREASING ENOUGH TO POSSIBLY
MATCH THE SENATE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT NEXT WEEK SCHOOL
BUDGET COMMITTEE IN THE PAPER
CLIMATE CHANGE WE MUST NOT
OVERLOOK THE CRITICAL ROLE THAT
ARE PROTECTED LANDS PLANE
CAPTURING AND STORING FRESH
WATER STORING CARBON PROTECTING
US FROM SEA LEVEL RISE AND
PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY. WE ARE
SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL FALLING
ITEMS INCLUDING FIVE HEARD
MILLION COULD WELL THAT
CONSERVATION BOARD SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BECAUSE
CONSERVANCY ACOSTA PROTECTION
SEALABLE RIGHT AFTERWARDS
ORDERED SIXTY MILLION PER SE
CONSERVANCY FOR CRIMINAL
INVESTMENT AND THIRTY MILLION
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION CHARGEABLE. BIFOCALS
AT THIS GRANT PROGRAM. WE AN
UNPRECEDENTED FINANCIAL. TO A
THE CALL BY THE- QUITE. IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWO BY TOO MANY
ACTION THE SCALE. TO PROVIDE
FIRST PRIVATE IN A MORE
SUSTAINABLE. WE PRETTY YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FOR YOUR
RESPECT AND YOUR RESPECTIVE
STAFF FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS I MEAN IMPORTANT
ISSUES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING CHECHNYA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION ACCOUNT ALSO
SPEAKING THIS MORNING FOR MY
COLLEAGUES UTC IN RC RC ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BROADBAND PROPOSAL-
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
RELEASED LAST NIGHT INCLUDES
FULL FUNDING FOR LAST MILE
CONSTRUCTION INCLUDES RATE
RELIEF FOR SHORT TERM-
AFFORDABILITY AND INCLUDES THE
ONLY LONG TERM SOLUTION TO BOTH
UNIVERSAL SERVICE AND
AFFORDABILITY WHICH IS A STATE
WIDE OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE MILE
NETWORK. I'VE HEARD ARGUING
THAT THE MIDDLE MILE FUNDING
WOULD BE WASTED MONEY WHEN
THEY'RE REAL REASON FOR
OPPOSING LET'S BE CLEAR ISN'T A
SUDDEN CONCERN TO THE STATE'S
FISCAL PRUDENCE IT'S RETAINING
THEIR MONOPOLIES OVER NEARLY
HALF OF THE COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE THAT WE DIRECTLY TO THE
ON AFFORDABLE RATES LOW SPEEDS
AND PAINLESSLY TERRIBLE
CUSTOMER SERVICE THIS ISN'T THE
TIME TO DELAY ON THE ON
BROADBAND BUT THE LATE JUST A
COUPLE OF MONTHS WILL LOSE US
AND ENTIRE CONSTRUCTION SEASON
WE HAVE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DOLLARS IN AND- FOR THIS
PURPOSE RIGHT NOW. AND WE
SHOULD USE THEM THE NEED IS
URGENT AND WE URGE YOU TO ADOPT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BROADBAND
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK. LINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN MEMBERS BEST-
ALSO ON BEHALF OF WATER REUSE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
STATE'S WATER RECYCLERS WERE
EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF
SECRETARY CLOSE BUT IS QUOTED
IN THE LA TIMES ON MONDAY
SAYING THAT ONE OF THE REASONS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ISN'T. I
NEXT YEAR EXTRAPOLATIONS YET IS
BECAUSE OF WATER RECYCLING HOW
CAN I DROUGHT PACKAGE NOT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN NEW
SOURCES OF WATER RECYCLE ARE IS
CRUCIAL TO CREATING LOCAL AND
REGIONAL WATER CIVILLY AT
RESILIENCE AND WE SUPPORT AT
LEAST SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE FINAL
DROP PACKAGE. FOR RECYCLED
WATER THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SPEND
INTO A COMBAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
WERE DISAPPOINTED WITH THE SUB
COMMITTEE ACTION REJECT THE ABA
CLEAN AIR PROGRAM FUNDING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WHICH
INCLUDES THE COM WHERE PROGRAM
IN EIGHTY NINE TWENTY THREE
LOCAL INCENTIVES PROGRAM WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
RECONSIDER AS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE APPROVING
THE EXTENSION THIS YEAR WILL
ALLOW FOR PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE
SEAMLESSLY HELP INFORM STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
DEVELOPMENT. AND PROVIDE
BUSINESS AND MARKET CERTAINTY
WE APPRECIATE PROPOSED FUNDING
FOR EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN AND
FIND THE PROGRAM INCENTIVES AND
IN LIGHT OF THE BUDGET SURPLUS
URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TO FURTHER PRIORITIZE
THESE PROGRAMS FOR FUNDING WE
MUST EXPRESS THAT WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE FIFTY MILLION
FOR A DISTRICT EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION IT
DOES NOT COVER CURRENT COSTS
ACCOUNT FOR ME COMMUNITIES
ADDED TO THE STATE MANDATED
PROGRAM. LAST WEEK SUPPORT THE
SENATE FUNDING FOR THE
RESIDENTIAL WOOD SMOKE
REDUCTION PROGRAM THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. MY SIXTY YEAR IS- OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TERM BLOOM AND
NUMBER THE COMMITTEE PAUL MASON
WITH BECAUSE OF THE COST PLUS
FIRST OFF THANK YOU FOR RUNNING
A GOOD HEARING UNDER
EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT YEAR
AND VERY BIZARRE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AFTER TODAY'S HEARING I WANT TO
SPEAK TO THOSE IN THE RELATED
ISSUES OF WATER OR FIRE
ADVERSITY CLIMATE ADAPTATION
AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE ALL OF
THAT A LOT OF GOOD STUFF IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IT WAS
STRIKINGLY LACKING FOR FUNDING
FOR LAND CONSERVATION. AND
PROTECTING RESTORING AND
IMPROVING THE MANAGEMENT OF OUR
FORESTS WILDLIFE AND WATERSHEDS
OVER THE LONG TERM LIKE I'M
GOING TO EAT IT IN THE CENTRAL
PART OF A FUNCTIONAL LONG TERM
STRATEGY TO ACHIEVE RESILIENCE
FOR THE BENEFITS OF FIRE WATER
SECURITY CLIMATE. RESILIENCE
AND BIODIVERSITY- WE'RE
HEARTLESS CHEN THE NOTE- TRY TO
A LOT WITH THE SCALE OF AND BY.
AND CRIME- ACTIVITIES IN AFTER
WORKING LANDS OF THE SENATE HAD
TAKEN ACTION ON YESTERDAY. WE
URGE YOU TO WORK WITH THE
SENATE TO TRY AND AUGMENT THE-
ACTION IN THE NAY REVISED IN
ORDER TO MAKE THE APPROPRIATE
LEVELS OF INVESTMENT IN THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD. IT
CONSERVANCY IS THE ITEMS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE BECAUSE HER AT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY NORTH HUMAN
PEOPLE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING BILL
MY GOVERNMENT THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR- ITEM NINETY THREE
DISASTER PACKAGE WE APPRECIATE
THE STAFF COMMENTS SUPPORT FOR
CLEAN TRUCKS AND BUSES WHICH
ARE ESSENTIAL TO CLEANING UP
OUR AIR AND ALSO AGREED WITH
THE SUPPORT FOR E. BIKES WHICH
ARE AN EXCELLENT TOOL FOR
REDUCING EMISSIONS AND VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. WE URGE FUNDING
OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROJECT WHICH SHOULD INCLUDE
BUT NOT BE LIMITED TO CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL SHOULD ALSO
INCLUDE OTHER EQUITY PROJECTS
AND- I KNOW THAT THESE PROJECTS
ARE OUT OF MONEY. AND SO PEOPLE
ARE WAITING TO BE ABLE TO GET
INTO CLEAN SAFE RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION- ITEM NUMBER ONE
FORTY SIX WE SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENTS IN TRANSIT AND RAIL
AND L. A. TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
TRANSPORTATION AND ZERO MISSION
TRANSLITERATE AND URGED A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. AN ITEM
SEVENTEEN WE DO SUPPORTER WE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE AB EIGHT
CLEAN AIR AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS. I'LL
ALSO SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE HEAVY DUTY INSPECTION
AND MAINTENANCE PROGRAM UNDER
S. B. TWO TEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JOSHUA SHOP FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO'S MAYOR
LONDON BREED AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY SPEAKING
TO ISSUES. SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE NINETY NINE ONE OH EIGHT
ONE ELEVEN ONE FORTY FOUR AND
ONE FORTY SIX AND WE'D LIKE TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
PUTTING FORWARD IN HIS MAY
REVISION A NUMBER OF LANDMARK
TRANSPORTATION AND ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE FUNDING
PROPOSALS AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE. TO APPROPRIATE THE
MAXIMUM FUNDS POSSIBLE TO
SUPPORT PUBLIC TRANSIT ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND NEEDED INVESTMENTS TO
ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION OF
OUR VEHICLE FLEETS TO ZERO
EMISSIONS THANKS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MAGGIE MUNSON FOR
THE SANTA ANA WATERSHED PROJECT
IS ALREADY. IN REGARDS TO BE
DROUGHT PACKAGE STOP A
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS FIVE
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL
WATER MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS I. R.
W. M. ARE PROVING REGIONAL
PROGRAMS THAT CAN IN BACKING
REGIONAL SOLUTION TO DROUGHT
IMPACT THROUGHOUT THE DAY AND
AS NOTED BY THE L. A. O. IN
TODAY'S AGENDA. AT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WORTHY OF FUNDING
BY THE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAPLAIN THE MEMBERS CARE
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE CITY OF
SOLANA BEACH IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE FORTY FISCAL STABILITY
PROVIDING PROGRAMS AND VERY
SPECIFICALLY THE PRESERVATION
OF THE BEACH SAND REPLENISHMENT
PROGRAM THIS IS A CRITICAL
PROGRAM THAT IS HEAVILY
LEVERAGE WITH FEDERAL FUNDS TO
PROTECT OUR PUBLIC BEACHES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA.
EKING ON BEHALF OF ISSUE ONE
FORTY SIX TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE PROPOSALS
IN THE ACTION YOU JUST TOOK- IN
SUPPORT OF SPECIFICALLY TO
PRIORITY RAIL AND TRANSIT
PROJECTS ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING HIGH PRIORITY GRADE
SEPARATIONS ZERO MISSION RAIL
TRANSIT EQUIPMENT PURCHASES.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE- AND SO ON
AT TE SAME TIME WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT MORE CAN BE DONE
WITH THE STATE'S ONCE ALL OF
STATE AND FEDERAL REVENUES AT
TO SUPPORT TRANSPORTATION AND
OTHER RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE PRIME
CANDIDATES FOR ONE TIME
INVESTMENT HELP CREATE AND
SUSTAIN LIVING WAGE JOBS. AND
CREATE POSITIVE RIPPLE EFFECTS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE ECONOMY-
SPECIFICALLY WE ARE SUPPORT OF
THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF ONE TIME
AUGMENTATIONS OF TWO
OVERSUBSCRIBED HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE SB ONE GRANT
PROGRAMS SUPPORTING TRADE
CORRIDORS IN SOLUTIONS FOR
CONGESTED CORRIDORS. SUPPORT
AUGMENTATIONS FOR
OVERSUBSCRIBED HARRY BRIDGE
PROGRAM LOCAL SYSTEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MENTION OR ACKNOWLEDGE
OF WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER HERE
SPEAKING ON A VARIETY OF ISSUES-
IN LIGHT OF THE RECORD BUDGET
SURPLUS FUNDS ARE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGES ALL PARTIES TO-
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED THE
FUNDING ALLOCATED TOWARDS-
CLIMATE. TARGETS SPECIFICALLY
WE ARE LOOKING TO SEE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TOWARD COMMUNITY ENERGY
RESILIENCY PROGRAM SO THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO START
PLANNING CHIU WEATHER EMERGENCY
GREAT OUTAGES WITH CLEAN.
ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE SIGNIFICANT INCREASES
IN THE NATIONAL SICKLE STRETCH
AND- ALLOCATIONS AND WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION WE AUTHORIZED
EIGHTY EIGHT APPLICATIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU IN ADVANCE OF
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
AN ISSUE SEVENTEEN WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
AUTHORIZATION ABA PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE BUDGET PROCESS.
CARRYING OUT CAN SPONSOR
MESSENGER THE JACKSON CLIMATE
CHANGE ACCORDING TO HOW STAGE
DISPATCH COMMUNITIES AND
BILLING ROCKERS ATIONS DELAY
SEVENTY THE ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS I'M SURE NINETY THREE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT PROPOSED
INVESTMENT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF LIGHT MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES THIS YEAR-
THE DIESEL FACILITY CAN
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE BEST
IN A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
JACKIE DAY SERVICE IN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS TO
MATCH PROGRAM DEMAND SUPPORT A
GLOBAL TRANSITION ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. ADDITIONALLY NINE
BECAUSE MAJERUS THE PROJECT
PROPOSAL SYSTEM FUNDING LEVEL
SECURITIES INVESTMENT IS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO DELIVER
CRITICAL CLIMATE AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AT GEORGE LASTLY- ISSUE
ON FORTY SIX WE SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO MOVE
POSSIBLE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FORWARD BUT ALSO
RECOMMEND FOR MORE URGENT
ACTION ON THE- STRUCTURE.
ELEMENTS THANK YOU VERY. THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY YEARS IS OPEN.
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WON
AT THANK CHAIRMAN BLOOM
HUNDREDS HEARING IN DOCTOR
ACCORDING ARE DRY FIRE AND
HIGHLIGHTING WHAT CAN CAN DO. A
HERE VOTE WILL AFFECT OF KILLED
AMERICA. THE CALIFORNIA LAW OF-
NURSE FOR HELP IN I AM A
REGISTERED NURSE. WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CHEN AFTER TRYING TO
INTO FRIENDLY SAMPLE I RECALL.
BUT WIND FARM THEIR IN THEIR
QUEUE HAVE LITTLE OR NO. FROM
EXPOSURE TO PASS A WITH CAUSED
THE Q. AND AS WELL AS LONG TERM
ELEMENTS IT'S- THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT UPDATING THE
CHEERING OF MET ALPHA SITE
MELFI AND HOPE THIS WILL BE
ADDED TO THE BUDGET WE HAVE TO
DISENCHANTED BY THE USE OF
DANGEROUS PESTICIDES ON ON
GOING BASIS. WE HAVE PARTY
SOMEPLACE PROPOSED PLAN FOR AN
ARM FUNDING FOR TRANSITION OUT
WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE CONSIDER
ADDING. A SPECIFIC- PROPOSAL
FOR FUNDING. THE ACTUAL
COMMUNITIES AFFECTED SO THEY
CAN CHOOSE- PROTECTION FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AS YOU FINALIZE
THE BUDGET WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
INCLUDE OUR- PREFERENCE FOR
ORGANIC FOOD AND ALL FOOD
PROCUREMENT. LODGE WE SHOULD BE
BUYING SANCTIONS COURAGE
CHILDREN AND OUR SENIORS AND
STATE CAN USE THE MARKET TO BE
A PART SHE SUPPORT HEALTHY
AGRICULTURE THANK YOU CLASS OF
EVERYONE. ASSOCIATED THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS A-
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN THAT
YOUR THUMB BEHALF WITH
ASSOCIATES ACCOUNT WTER
AGENCIES WANT TO SPEAK ON ISSUE
NINETY ONE I JUST FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
MEMBERS AS WELL AS YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE SPEAKERS THAT
WERE LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
WE FULLY SUPPORT THE SENATE
PROPOSAL AS WELL AS PARTS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDING THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS- INTERMARRIAGES- A FEW
ADDITIONAL CATEGORIES TO
CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL COMES
TOGETHER I'M FIRST FUNDING FOR
DAM SAFETY WHICH IS NOT
INCLUDED IN EITHER THE SENATE
OR ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL-
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR PEOPLE
AFTER MEDIATION FUNDING FOR
REGIONAL CONVEYANCE. ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR RECYCLED WATER AND
FUNDING FOR HABITAT RESTORATION
PROJECTS AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN APPLE EXPORT
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS CONVERSATION
REPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CAN NUMBER THIS
IS ALSO SHAUNA WHAT'S AT THE
SIDE ACTION NETWORK COMMENTING
ON ISSUE FORTY EIGHT FORTY NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
MAKING OUR AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM
MORE JUST AND MORE SUSTAINABLE
ALWAYS FELT STRONGLY SUPPORT A
DEER CLASSIFIED NO FEE THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSED FUNDING FOR
TRANSITION TO PAY FOR
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
INCLUDES ITEMS THAT WE SUPPORT.
INCLUDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND RESEARCH THAT WILL HELP
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS
MANAGED HAVE FAITHFULLY A
POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM AND
AFFECTED BY NOTIFICATION
NETWORK YEP EXACTLY THREE WITH
INCLUDING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
CALLING THE PESTICIDE CARE
MONITORING AND ENFORCEMENT
HOWEVER WE ARE DISAPPOINTED.
THAT THE PROPOSED FUNDING AMID.
FUNDING FOR DIRECT PROTECTION
FOR COMMUTE UPON BY PUBLIC YOU.
WITH THE COURT THAT'S NOT
MILLION IN THE PACKAGE FOR CAN
YOU AT THE CORE FUNDS IF. THE
CAN IS NOT IMPACT BY HUNDRED
PASSED BY WHICH ARE PRIMARY
PEOPLE OF COLOR TO THERMAL.
SUCH IMPACT BURDEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION ON TWO
ITEMS ON NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
THEIR CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PACKAGE WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
INCORPORATE THE AMOUNT
SUGGESTED IN OUR MAY TWENTY SIX
LETTER CO SIGNED BY OVER FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS WITH PARTICULAR
EMPHASIS ON THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ADAPTATION PLANS FIFTY MILLION
FOR STATE. EXCUSE ME FOR
REGIONAL GOVERNOR GOVERNMENT
LEADERSHIP AND FIFTY MILLION
FOR REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE
GROUPS CONSISTENT WITH EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY SEVEN ON ITEM
NINETY ONE THE DROUGHT PACKAGE
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
SUGGESTION OF THREE HUNDRED
MILLION PER SEGMENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR LAND REPURPOSE
SAYING CONSISTENT WITH OUR
LETTER OF MAY TWENTY SIX ALSO
SIGNED BY A NUMBER OF. OTHER
GROUPS THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BECAUSE OF THE S.
YOUR POLICY MANAGER FOR
CHARGEPOINT CHARGEPOINT SUPPORT
STAFF RECOMMENDATION
SUBCOMMITTEE APPROVED OF ALL OF
OUR RESOURCES WILL SEEK
CLARIFICATION ON A FEW THE
PROUD. PROGRAMMATIC ALLOCATION
THEN ISSUE NINETY THREE. POINT
PURCHASE OF COMMITTEES ALLOCATE
INVENTORY. CAN YOU OF THE ZERO
INFRASTRUCTURE. SERVICES LIKELY
TO VEHICLE TO INFRASTRUCTURE IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE OKAY FUND
FOR THEY WILL BE IMMEDIATELY
USED BY COOPER RESIDENTS TRAVIS
ALLEN TRAVIS. MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY
INSPECTORS ALSO CORCORAN OF
CALIFORNIANS YOUR MISSION
VEHICLE AND CARBON REDUCTION
STRATEGY. AND IF YOU CAN
PROVIDE MORE INCENTIVES TO HELP
REDUCE COSTS AS FAR AS.
CONSTRUCTION WE THINK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. NINE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAPLAIN MEMBERS REBEKAH LONG
FOR THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INCREASE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING IN ISSUE
ONE FORTY SIX ESPECIALLY FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION REGARDING THE
RECOMMENDATION TO ADD NEW
PROJECT ELECTION PROVISIONS WE
WOULD NOTE THAT MOST OF THE
FUNDING WOULD AUGMENT EXISTING
PROGRAMS. THAT ALREADY HAVE
CLEAR AND EFFECTIVE GUIDELINES
THAT WERE DEVELOPED WITH
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND
HAVE PROJECT IN THE QUEUE THAT
ARE READY TO GO. REGARDING
ISSUE EIGHTY NINE ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
pFUNDING FOR LOCAL AND REGIONAL
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO ADDRESS THE EXTENT
IT NEEDS OF OUR FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO CITIES AND FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES. I LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN FOR HIS
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF REGIONAL PLAN ADAPTATION. IN
AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN- BLOOM AT
THE OUTSET AT OUTSET OF THE T.
OUR- IS CHANGING AND WE URGE
YOU TO ENSURE THIS BUDGET
ADEQUATELY INVEST IN THE
CRITICAL. MY TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARTIN
ESPINOSA JUNIOR CALLING ON
BEHALF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS REGIONAL COUNCIL WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
SPECIFICALLY AN ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
SIX ZERO AND TWENTY SIX SIX
FIVE REGARDING HIGH SPEED ROLL
AN APARTMENT TRANSPORTATION WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING. AND
MEMBERS IT IS QUITE TACKLE. AT
THE FOLLOW AND STORE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
HUNDRED MEMBER. YEAH ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF US WE WOULD LIKE TO
WARMLY THANK DESKTOP COME. AND
ABOUT SHE AND- EVERYONE WHO HAS
SPARKED PUT TOGETHER THIS WILL
BE. WE WILL IN PARTICULAR LIKE
TO YOU FOR INCLUDING IT MIN
DOLLAR. ALLOCATE TORRANCE AND
AUTOMATED CLAMPED CLAM.
MORE
MIST CHAU COMMITTED- JOE.
SPECIFICALLY ARE SUPPORTING THE
EFFORTS OF THE ASSEMBLY IS
DOING IN TERMS OF THE CLEAN
TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
FREIGHT EQUIPMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS MARK STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
OF THE DISTRICT ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHTY NINE ON THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE PACKAGE WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF FUNDING FOR THE
LOW INCOME WEATHERIZATION
PROGRAM IS CHAMPION BY SOMEONE
RAMBLING. AT THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM MAKES THREE KEY
ASSEMBLY PRIORITIES ONE IS THAT
REDUCES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS TO THAT HELPS BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THREE IT
BRINGS PRIVATE EQUITY BY
REDUCING UTILITY BILLS FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS AND WE PRUDENT
CREATE YOUR SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING. AN
APPROPRIATION THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
NUMBER TOLD ME AT THE LEAST
SHANTI HAPPENED Q. CLIENTS
BURST ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT ON ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND
NINETY NINE WITHIN WALKING
VALUE FACING ENORMOUS
CHALLENGES AND MEETING HEALTH
BASED AIR QUALITY ATTAINMENT
STANDARDS. AND THEN REDUCING
AIR POLLUTION AND EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES IN ORDER TO MEET
OUR OBLIGATIONS AS OUTLINED IN
OUR STATE IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM WE STRONGLY URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO SUPPORT THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF THE EIGHT
PROGRAM EIGHTY EIGHT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE COLUMN WHERE
PROGRAM. HE SUPPORT THE FUNDING
PROVIDED IN THE MAY REVISE FOR
THE FARMER PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES FOR AIR QUALITY AS
WELL AS ECONOMIC BENEFITS TO
THE VALLEY DISTRICT OFFICE
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
ALTERNATIVES TO ADD TO BERNIE
HOWEVER WE HOPE WE HOPE TO
SECURE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
FOR THE PRODUCT ENDING AS ERIC
WE HAVE DETERMINED THAT THE
NEED FOR THESE PROGRAMS IS MUCH
GREATER. LAST WEEK THE DISTRICT
SUPPORT INCREASED SPENDING FOR
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION AND INTEND TO
PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN- WE ACTUALLY
ASSEMBLY TO CONSIDER APPROVING
A PROPOSAL TO RE AUTHORIZE
EIGHTY EIGHT PROGRAM
DOCUMENTATION WILL PROVIDE
CERTAINTY FOR INVESTMENTS MADE
NOW IN THE NEAR FUTURE CREDIT.
PROGRAMS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE SEVENTY NINE
YEAR LINE OF THE MORNING CARE
MEMBERS DANIELLE BLACK BY WITH
CALIFORNIA FOR YOU TO THIS.
THANK YOU AND ALL OF YOUR WORK
AND LEADERS HE A SUPPORT ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN THE FOR CATS BRAD
CALLAGY IN CENTER I ISSUE
NUMBER NINE ONE WE'VE THE
INCLUSION OF THE THREE PLUS
BILL FOR DROUGHT RELIEF AND WE
LIKE THE ELEMENT THAT THE
SENATE PLAN. IT WILL HELP
MITIGATE DROUGHT IMPACT AND
HELP CUSTOMERS THE COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS THEM PUBLICLY AND
ALECTRA UTILITIES BUT THERE AND
EIGHT BILL AND WE URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO WORK WITH THE
SENATE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE RIGHT NEAR RELEASED THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT IN A
FAST AND EFFICIENT MANNER TO
PROVIDE EQUITABLE ACCESS
CUSTOMERS OF ALL STATE
UTILITIES AND HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY CARPET. WE ARE
LOSING SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS IN THESE AREAS CAN
COMPLEMENT OR BOTH YOU'RE THE
SENATE PLAN WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO FINALIZE THE BUDGET THAT
WILL ATTRACT DROUGHT IMPACT FOR
STATE RECOVERED FROM. AT
NINETEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRED IS
MARK MAKE BEHALF OF SUB CLIENTS
FIRST FOR WATER BOND ISSUE
NINETY ONE THE DROUGHT PACKAGE
WE SUPPORT MANY ELEMENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S NAY REVISION I
PARTICULARLY FUNDING FOR DATA
COLLECTION AND THE ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS RESEARCH AND WORK ON
FORECAST INFORMED RESERVOIR
OPERATIONS PIECE WHICH ENABLES
WATER AGENCIES LIKE OURS TO
PRESERVE MORE WATER IN DRY
TIMES. LIKE THE DROUGHT WE ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING I WE
WOULD REQUEST INCREASE FUNDING
AMOUNTS ABOVE WHAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES FOR WATER USE
EFFICIENCY BOTH IN THE URBAN
SETTING AND FOR AGRICULTURE AND
ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM WATER RE
USE THAT WE NEED MORE FUNDING
FOR WATER RECYCLING THESE ARE
ALL CRITICAL- ELEMENTS THE
BUILDING GREATER DROUGHT
RESILIENCY. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL LAND TRUST
AND ALLOWING CONSERVANCY WE
WERE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
REGARDS TO ITEM EIGHTY NINE ON
CLIMATE RESILIENCY THAT WE NEED
TO INVEST FUNDING AND WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND THE
CONSERVATIVES FOR REGIONAL
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PROJECTS.
AND LASTLY ON BEHALF OF
SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION I WAS
PART OF THE FUNDING FOR DFW FOR
THE CUTTING GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVE AND ISSUE THIRTY
THREE AND WE ASK THAT ADDITION
PERMITTING PROCESS IS BEING
USED IN FISHING WILDLIFE
PROTECTION ALLOCATIONS GOING
FORWARD THANK. YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. I NEED FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EACH MORNING
JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
THROUGHOUT IRRIGATION DISTRICT
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND SANTA MARGARITA
WATER DISTRICT I SPEAKING ON
ISSUE NINETY ONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SENATE DROUGHT
PROPOSAL ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS
FROM STIMULATE AQUA WE
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF FUNDING FOR ADD
WATER USE EFFICIENCY PROJECT. A
GROUND WATER QUALITY PROJECTS
INCLUDING SEPTIC TO SEWER
CONVERSIONS AND THE WATER
RECYCLING- FUNDING- THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OPERATOR MEDINA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND WE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
COMMON CONDITION NINETY ONE WAY
POPULOUS ENTRY IN YOUR WAY AND
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
COMMITTEE CAR YOUR WORK- WE
HOPE THAT- THE ISSUE RELATED TO
THE SOUTH AND SEE- THAT THE
ASSEMBLY INCLUDES A TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FALCONS TEAM THAT'S CURRENTLY.
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE THE FINAL PROPOSAL- THE
PROJECTS- WILL DEFINITELY HELP
SOME OF THE MOST ADVANCED
THEORIES THAT ALREADY IMPACTED
BY SOME OF THE WORST AIR
QUALITY IN THE STATE. I THANK
YOU AND. HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND%
MEMBERS AND STAFF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE CHANCE TO
TALK I'M DANIEL GLEASON CAMP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE
FOR BIODIVERSITY TO COMMENT ON
ISSUES FORTY EIGHT FORTY NINE
AND EIGHTY SEVEN- WE REALLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
AND YOUR YOU NOW YOUR
COMMITMENT TO MUCH NEEDED
CHANGING TRANSFORMATIONAL
INVESTMENTS- REGARDING
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT WE
SUPPORT YOUR PLAN FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO FARMERS PESTICIDE
NOTIFICATION. ASIDE ARE
MONITORING NETWORKS- WE'RE
SURPRISED AT THE LACK OF
FUNDING FOR A COMMUNITY SUPPORT
FUND WHICH YOU KNOW WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS FACING THE
GREATEST HARM FROM PESTICIDES
AND ALSO AT THE ABSENCE OF THE
DNA BARCODING FOR POLLINATORS-
THAT WAS REQUESTED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS KALRA BENNETT FRIEDMAN.
THREE OF US AND OTHERS. ON WE
WELCOME THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM
ASK TO HAVE A COUPLE PROBLEMS
FIXED- FIRST THOUGH THE WESTERN
MIGRATORY MONARCH IS GOING TO
BE EXTINCT IN A COUPLE YEARS.
AND SO WE NEED TO FIND THE
MONARCH RESCUE PROJECT IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES USING THAT THAT
FANCY NEW HABITAT. WE ALSO-
REALLY WE LACKED SEEDS FOR THE
EXISTING POLLINATOR HABITAT
PROJECTS THERE JUST AREN'T
ENOUGH SHE'D ALREADY. AND WE
NEED TO FUND A STATEWIDE
SEEDBANK IF WE HOPE TO SPEND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS GROWING
NEW POLLINATOR HABITAT THANK
YOU SO AS YOU FINISH BUDGET. WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL ENSURE THAT
THESE NEEDS ARE INCLUDED IN
YOUR DECISIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK THANK YOU. MY NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NINETY
ONE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THING UNTIL NINE
NINETY NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN BLOOM IN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OR THE
CONTENT OF THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF BURKE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT AND
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS SHOULD
BOTH METROPOLITAN AND THE
CONTRACTORS ARE SUPPORTED THAT
THE PROPOSED SPENDING FOR WATER
IN DROUGHT. RESILIENCY AS WELL
AS THE COPA NINETEEN FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO HELP RETAIL WATER
AGENCIES CLEAR CUSTOMER DEBTS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE SENATE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PACKAGES SH MORE SPECIFICALLY
WE ARE SUPPORTED THE WATER
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE IN
ADDITION THE NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS TO STRENGTHEN NATIVE
FISH POPULATIONS. AND WILDLIFE
TO CHANGING CLIMATE CONDITIONS.
SHIFTING BE HAPPENING. WE THE
SENATE TO INCREASE FUNDING PER.
WATER PROJECTS RECYCLED WATER
INTO DROPLETS TO PLY AND THERE
IS AN IDENTIFIED TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
PROJECTS THAT ARE SHOVEL READY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE ALL
TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR MONITORING TREATMENT OF
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINANTS LIKE
P. FAST ADDRESSING CONSISTENT
CONSTITUENTS THAT EMERGENT
EMERGING CONCERNS AND URBAN
WATER USE EFFICIENCY.
METROPOLITAN AND THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS WILL BE
SHARING COPIES OF OUR LETTERS
THAT OUTLINED OUR PRIORITIES
WITH YOUR COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. MY
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KIM
DELFINO HE HAPPENED SEVERAL
CLIENTS- DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
IN THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY SUPPORTS THE ASSEMBLY
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WHILE I
FUNDING ISSUES THIRTY ONE TO
THIRTY FIVE AND WE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BENNETT'S
COMMENTS REGARDING THE PER
BARREL OIL P. WE WANT TO THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF SECURING
SUFFICIENT FUNDING. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
ISSUE EIGHTY NINE DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE STNG THE NORMAL
INTEREST IN FUTURE DOUBLE TRUCK
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
EXPENDITURES METHODS CLIMATE
PACKAGE AND URGE THAT ANY FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND THE
CONSERVANCY. CONSISTENT WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE URGE THAT ANY
FUNDING THAT FUNDING FOR THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY ALSO
INCLUDE FUNDING TO REMOVE
OBSOLETE DANCE UNDER THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
FUNDING WE URGE THE FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT INCLUDES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
AND FISH PASSAGE AS WELL AS
CONSERVATION FUNDING FOR OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE NOT
CURRENTLY START BY CONSERVANCY.
SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA DESERT
BREEZE YOU NINETY ONE HUNDRED
TWO OTHER SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
RECOMMENDATION PARTICULARLY
FUNDING FOR THIS POLICY AND
ADELINE MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
MADE BY EX JENNIFER SCARY I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE BENEFIT
WILDLIFE DOES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN REGARDING
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR LAND REPURPOSE THEM WITHOUT
ANY. DIRECTION TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC FUNDING WILL PROVIDE.
PUBLIC BENEFIT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. TWO ONE THIRD
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN BUT YOU'RE NO
INJURY ACTUALLY HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF CLIENTS
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK FROM LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI- SUPPORT FOR
ISSUE- ONE FORTY SIX- ONE-
ISSUE NINETY ONE- SPECIALLY-
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING FOR WATER RECYCLING.
ISSUE NINETY THREE- WE ASK
ABOUT WHAT'S BEING DISCUSSED BE
AUGMENTED BY TWO POINT TWO FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS PROJECT TRUCKS
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND.
FOCUS ON WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
L. A. METRO ISSUE NINE THREE.
H. OF COURSE WE HAVE
INVESTMENTS THEIR ISSUE NINETY
NINE CAP AND TRADE FUNDING.
ISSUE ONE OH EIGHT- CLEAN
CALIFORNIAN ISSUE ISSUE ONE
FORTY FOUR TDA- TRAILER BILL.
SUPPORT THE RELIEF THERE- FOR
METRO ON THE DECK PACKAGE- WE
PLEDGE TO OUR CHANGE ON OUR
FLEET YOUR MISSION BUSES. TEN
YEARS REFORM THE MANDATE BY THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THAT'S ALSO
TRUE FOR THE ONLY PARKING
TRANSPORTATION. THE LARGEST
MUNICIPAL BUS OPERATORS TO
CALIFORNIA. ALSO CERTAINLY
METRO ARE THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING PACKAGE
IF YOU WANT FORTY SIX. FOR
METROLINK WE ALSO SUPPORT-
ISSUE ONE FORTY SIX ESPECIALLY
THE FOCUS. FOUR HUNDRED SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO DEMONSTRATE
YOUR MISSION OF BRAILLE THANK
YOU FOR THE FRESNO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY SHE
WON ONLINE. FOR CATERPILLAR
ISSUE ONE ISSUE. EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY NAME
THREE YEAR LAW IS OPEN. THANK
YOU TERRY NUMBERS TO IN JORDAN
WITH THERE'S A COUPLE FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY-
FIRST WE HAVE TO THE ASSEMBLY
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR THE
TRANSFORMERS COMIC COMMUNITIES
AND ENSURE INVESTMENTS AND
DISADVANTAGED UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS
INVESTED IN COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC SPACES FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCE CONVERGENCE YOU
READING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
ACCESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. ADDITIONALLY FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN PLANS MUST
INCLUDE SUBSTANTIAL AND
QUANTIFIABLE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. TO ENHANCE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS. WE
SUPPORT THE RIVER PROVIDED
LEAST ONE BILL FOR DEBT RELIEF
AND THEN BY STATE WATER AND
ASKED THAT THE FUNDING GET OUT
VERY QUICKLY WITHOUT ONEROUS
INCOME VERIFICATION OR
APPLICATION OF COATED IMPACT.
WE CONTINUE TO ASK FOR NO
FUNDING- TO BE ALLOCATED FOR
GARY I JUST THERE'S ANY
PROGRAMS. WE SUPPORT TEN
MILLION FOR THE STATE LIKE THAT
THE FACT THAT. APPETITE
NOTIFICATION PROGRAM AS WELL
THE CHAIRED HERE NOPE THE
INCREASE BUT REMAIN DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE PROPOSAL
CONTINUES BUT LET'S FUNDING FOR
DIRECT COMMUNITIES PROTECTIONS.
SUCH AS BUFFERING GREENSPACE
PHONE APPLICATION A PROTECTIVE
GEAR FOR WORKERS. RAFFI TWENTY
MILLION FOR THIS PURPOSE TO BE
DIRECTED BY THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITY. LASTLY WE HAVE FOR
ONE BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
FOR INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION. THE CHALLENGES
THAT CHALLENGES THE MISINFORMED
CLASSES AND RACES BELIEVES THAT
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR CAN'T HAVE HIGH QUALITY
JOBS. CAREER OPPORTUNITIES
CLEAN WATER AND CLEAN AIR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY FIVE
JULY IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARPLY IN THE NUMBERS LIKE
MANY LONELY ENVIRONMENT PUT THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
I'M CALLING TODAY ISSUE NINETY
DEGREES AND THEIR MISSION YEAH
BACKAGE THAT SHE SEVENTEEN THE
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WE'D
LIKE EXPECT RESTAURANTS
CORPORATE GOVERNOR SPENDING
PROPOSAL FOR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. IN ELECTRIC
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
RESPECTFULLY ARGUE TO APPROVE
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT WE
OPERATE IN THE EAST CRITICALLY
ACCREDITATION PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT THE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR
THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT OR SEE THE I. P. AND WE
AGREE WITH THE FACT COMMON THAT
LIMIT EASIER PETER LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS ONLY MAKE THAT
INTERSECTION TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE WILL TRULY TRANSFORM THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION MARKET.
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSED FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS RECEIVE
EUROPEAN INADEQUATE TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE CLASS ACT
WITH WHICH YOU GET CALLED. THE
NUMBER PROVIDED CANNOT BE
DEFERRED OFFICIALLY WITH THE
FACT YOU CAN ACTUALLY USE WHICH
CURRENTLY HAS THOUSAND
APPLICANTS LOYALISTS. THANK YOU.
BURKE THANKS TO BACK IN EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS THIS IS YOU CAN OF THE
ALLIANCE WITH FOR. CAL STRONGLY
SUPPORTS IN YOUR ONE IN NEW FOR
TRANSITION TO AGRO IN TECHNICAL
FOR UNDERSERVED FARMERS FARM TO
SCHOOL CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE URBAN AGRICULTURE
BEGINNING FARMER AND FARMWORKER
TRAINING AND THE STATEWIDE
PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION NETWORK
CAP URGES THAT THE FINAL
ADOPTED BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES.
TEN MILLION FOR TOOL SHARING
LIBRARIES FOR SMALL SCALE
FARMERS AN ADDITIONAL EVENTEEN
MILLION FOR FOOD HUBS TO
DEVELOP MARKET PATHWAYS FOR
FARMERS TO ACCESS INSTITUTIONAL
MARKETS AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION FOR BEGINNING FARMER
AND FARMWORKER TRAINING. AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHT MILLION FOR
THE BASED PROGRAM AND A TEAR TO
PESTICIDE MIL TREAT TO FIND
MORE INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
RESOURCES AND COMMUNITY
PROTECTION. FINALLY THANK YOU
FOR INCLUDING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT THE
ENHANCED PACIFIED AIR
MONITORING NETWORK WILL BE
LINKS TO OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT. ACTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. Q. ONE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
MAYOR DARRELL STEINBERG IN THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO WE'RE
CALLING ABOUT THE NAY REVISED
PROPOSAL FOR THE SECOND IN A
ROW YOU'RE NOT LOSING TODAY'S
AGENDA WE WOULD URGE YUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET WELL AS-
WE MOVE FOR IN THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLOOMING
MEMBERS I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON
ISSUE ONE FORTY SIX THIS IS
MIKE WHAT MEN CHAIR OF THE
NORTH STATE SUPER REGION AND
THE NORTE TO RETURN REPRESENTS
A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
SIXTEEN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AGENCY THE
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATION. WITH THE PURPOSE
IS TO PROVIDE A UNIFIED VOICE
WHEN ADDRESSING STATE AND
FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
IN POLICY DECISION. BY THE
NORTH STATE SUPER REGION
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE THE PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
IN TRANSPORTATION HOWEVER I
REFER BACK REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR ADDITIONAL AUGMENTATION FOR
THE KEY TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
AS REQUESTED BY TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA. AND THE BROAD
SUPPORT- FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION TRADE AND LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS THE AUGMENTATIONS
OUTLINED IN THEIR REQUEST-
PROVIDE DESPERATELY NEEDED
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE
READY TO BE DELIVERED BUT
SIMPLY LACKED THE FUNDING AND
WILL HELP REDUCE THE BACKLOG OF
UNFUNDED PROJECT IN NEED OVER
SURPRISED PROGRAM- THE PROJECT
WILL HELP TO ADVANCE SAFETY
CLIMATE AND MULTIMODAL GOAL-
GET THE HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE
REQUESTED- CRITICAL TO THE
NORTH STATE SUPER REGION-
INCREASINGLY ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM TO ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. ONLY 11% OF
THE PROJECT WE'RE ABLE TO BE
FUNDED IN THE LAST CYCLE AND UP
FIVE HUNDRED PROPOSED IN THE
MAY REVISED- ONLY FUNDS PROJECT
CAN DO A SCORE OF EIGHTY SIX
AND THE CUT OFF NINETY ONE BUT%
WE NEED SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THERE ARE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR THE HIGHWAY BRIDGE PROGRAM
THE LOCAL SYSTEM COMPONENT. AND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
HIGHWAY SAFETY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM LOCAL COMPONENT- ALL OF
THOSE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE
OTHER PROGRAMS IN THEIR
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA-
REQUESTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
ADVANCING CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM AND WE
HAVE THE UNIQUE KIND OF
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS ONE TIME
SURPLUS TO AUGMENT THESE
PROGRAMS. AND REALLY CUTTING
BACK LOG. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NINE OH THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH MICHAEL BOOK A
GIRL BRAG ENERGY CONSUMERS AND
FULL SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR DAIRY METHANE
REDUCTION INCLUDING THE DERRY
DIGEST A PROGRAM THE RECENT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS COURT
DOCUMENTS THE THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS INVESTED TO DATE NUMBER
FIFTY CLIMATE PROJECTS. ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION AT THAT
THIRTEEN BILLION OR JUST ONE
POINT 5% HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO
THE DIGESTIVE PROGRAM TO DATE
THAT PROGRAM IS PROVIDING A
FULL 29% OF ALL GHG REDUCTION
ALL FIFTY PROGRAMS. PUT SIMPLY
ONE POINT 5% OF THE INVESTMENT
IS JUST GENERATING 29% OF THE
RETURNS ARGUMENTS TO NOT SEND
THIS PROGRAM ARE MISGUIDED AND
CONTRARY TO THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS AND SUGGESTION THAT THIS
PROGRAM DOES NOT PROVIDE
SUBSTANTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS ARE EQUALLY MISGUIDED
AND LACKING ANY FOUNDATION
THAT. THE TREMENDOUS
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS PROVIDED
BY THIS PROGRAMS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE WELL DOCUMENTED
BY STATE. AGENCIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEMBERS HASN'T
CHANGED OUT THE WRITING
COMMENTS FOR SEVERAL
ORGANIZATIONS ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSED FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION TO DOT FOR A MULTI
BENEFIT LABOR PARKING PROGRAM
IN THE NAY REVISION. AB TWO
FIFTY TO THE BILL AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH A PROGRAM
HAVE A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT AND JUST HAVE THAT
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE LAST
WEEK SO WE ENCOURAGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDE SUBSTANTIAL
FUNDING FOR IN THE FINAL BUDGET
AGREEMENT- I HAVEN'T CALIFORNIA
TRANSPARENT WITH LIMITED I
WANTED EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
THE CONSERVATION INVESTMENT
PROPOSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
PATHETICALLY ENCOURAGE
INCLUDING FIFTEEN MILLION FOR
THE CORRESPONDING PROGRAM. IN
THE FINAL BUDGET AS PROPOSED BY
THE SENATE I'M HAPPY PARK THE
PARK NOW COALITION MEMBERS
INCLUDING WORKING OUTDOORS IN A
FULL I'D LIKE EXPECT THE COURT
TO THE ONE BILLION IN THE MAY
REVISION TO PROMOTE OUTDOOR
ACCESS AND EQUITY. I THINK
WE'VE FORTY MILLION FOR THE
OUTDOOR EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM
FORTY MILLION FOR EXPORT
PROGRAM WHICH WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE AND
LAUGHING AT THE TOP OF THE
FLOOR INDEPENDENTLY I WANTED TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE REFORMS
FOR ONE STATE ACCESS THE LEVEL
RIGHT BUT AGAIN MENTIONED THE
NEED FOR REFORM AT THE PUMP
COMMISSION. WHICH DIDN'T
RECEIVE FUNDING IN THE MAY
REVISION AND REALLY HOPE THAT
THERE ARE RESOURCES FOR THE
WILL HELP BRANDS. AND THE.
LEVEL RIGHT PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS A- GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN DANIEL BOONE ON BEHALF
OF SE HA CAL BAR JUSTICE
ALLIANCE. THEY HAVE BEEN
MEETING WITH OFFICES SEPARATELY
UNDER BUT THE PARTY BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO MENTION A FEW BUT
REQUIRED EACH YEAR FIRST THEY
HAVE REQUESTED A NEW ONE
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS WHICH OUR
COMMUNITY LAND AND COMMUNITY
CENTER PROJECT. THEY ALSO
REQUESTED THE LOW INCOME
WHETHER IT'S- CAN IMPRINT THAT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TO FUND
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND WEATHER
STATION. UPGRADES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THE
COURT THE GUY GROUP FOR A
HUNDRED AND MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE TRANSFORMER COMIC UNITIES
GRANT- THE PLAN COMMUNITY LED
RESILIENCE PLANS AND LASTLY
STATE HAVE REQUESTED ALL
FUNDING FOR GERRI DIED
YESTERDAY CONTAMINATE GROUND
WATER AND INCREASE AIR
POLLUTION BE ELIMINATED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIVE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLAN AHEAD I'M SORRY I WAS
ON MUTE I THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS ELECTED TO HIGH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND ON
EACH YEAR EIGHTY NINE THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY WE
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENTS WE
SPEND A STRONG PROPONENT OF.
THE BOND THAT ARE MOVING
THROUGH BUT AFTER ABOUT MOVES
THROUGH AND FORWARD AND YOU I'M
DELIVERY DETAILS THAT THERE BE
ADVANCE PAYMENT FOR AGENCIES
AND FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THAT THE
ELIGIBILITY I'D BE EXTENDED TO
ALL WHO ARE ALREADY DOING THE
WORK SO THAT WE'RE LOCAL AGENCY
IS ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT WORK
AND- APPLY FOR GRANTED SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WOULD ALSO BE
ELIGIBLE. AND IN REGARDS TO
YOUR AND IF YOU THIRTY SECS
OUTDOOR FOR ALL AND I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW ESPECIALLY
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM RELIEF FUNDING ERIN TODAY
AND STATE IS IMPACTING IN.
OUTDOOR ACCESS AND EXPANSION OF
PARKS AND RECREATION AND GIVE
OTHER SERVICES THAT ARE WORK
REACHING DISTRICTS PERFORMS
ALREADY CONTINUE TO BE LEFT OUT
OF FUNDING AND MAYBE-
APPROPRIATE TO CONSIDER A GRANT
PROGRAM TO EXTEND TO SPECIAL
DISTRICTS YOU HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES. AND WITH REGARD TO
ISSUE FIFTY THE AMERICANS WERE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE ABOUT
FUNDING AND WITH EXCUSE AFTER
THE COMMENTS OF THE MILLION
AKHLAQ AHMAD YOU PREFERRED THE
SENATE VERSION AND WHAT IF YOU
NINETY TWO WILDFIRE FOR
THRILLING FEES ARE SIMILAR
COMMENTS IF YOU THIRTY SIX AND
OUR FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT IN
THE DISTRICT TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES. CONTINUE TO BE LEFT
OUT OF BINDING AND WE WOULD-
APPS FOR YOU TO CONSIDER.
ANYTHING TO THEM THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH FOUR. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CERBAT JUST AT THE FOR
NASA SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
A TWENTY THOUSAND SCHOOL
LEADERS AND AT WE BELIEVE OUR
STERN HAVE A TO HIGH.
AFFORDABLE EDUCATION SYSTEM AND
CARBON UNFORTUNATELY REVEALED
THE REALITY OF THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE WE SUPPORT ITEM NINETY
FOUR THE GOVERNOR'S BOLD
INVESTMENT A ONE TIME RESOURCES
TO MAKE SERIOUS STRIDES TO HELP
TO STAY CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
LACK BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RELIABILITY. THIS PLANT HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO TRANSFORM NOT
ONLY THE QUALITY OF HER
EDUCATION BUT THE QUALITY OF
LIFE FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WE HOPE THAT YOU
RECONSIDER THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING I'M ALEX
TUDOR RIGHT- SUNDRIED SYSTEM-
WE ARE SOLD COMPANY LOCATED AT
PASADENA AND DID YOU HAVE TO
SUPPORT OF ALLOCATING TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
EXPEDITED SOLAR PERMITTING
SUPPORT FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DURING CODE
WE SAW THE INEQUALITY OF ONLINE
OR VIDEO CROSS OF THE LEGION.
OF MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND STAFF
CAPACITY TO IMPLEMENT AUTOMATED
TERMINATES FUNDING IS CRITICAL
TO COVER THE STAFF TIME AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH SETTING
UP THE ONLINE SYSTEM AND
TRAINING STAFF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. ONE ONE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHARON MEMBERS
JERRY DESMOND ON BEHALF OF
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE BUDGET ITEM
LOCAL READERS GHOST ABILITY
PROMOTING PROGRAMS WE SUPPORT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE FIRST IN
ADDITIONAL COMMITMENT OF
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THE WATER TEMPERATURE MORE
COMFORTABLE BEING FUN AS WELL
TURN IT UP TO A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN BOTH REGISTRATION
FEES AND SECOND. HUNDRED PRO
BILL LANGUAGE- THAT WOULD
REQUIRE STATE PARKS TO CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS TO REVIEW THE
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE OF THE
REVOLVING FUND AFRICA
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS THE
LONG TERM VIABILITY FUND
SOURCES OF REVENUE AND
EXPENDITURES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE FEES AND TAXES PAID BY
THE VOTING PUBLIC PROVIDE THE
MAXIMUM ACHIEVABLE BENEFITS.
FOR THE FUTURE ON THE WATER
RECREATION. OUR THE PRESS OF
THE PEACE SAND. PROGRAM THAT'S
BEEN DISCUSSED BY A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A KEY TOPIC FOR THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS. THIS
PROGRAM BENEFITS MANY
CALIFORNIANS IS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE DISCUSSION ON
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SEA LEVEL
RISE AND SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
FOR STATE FUNDING WITHIN THAT
CONTEXT. WE ALSO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS REQUIRES
THE APPOINTMENT OF
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE KEY
STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATIONS.
REQUIRES THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP
PROCESS TO BE CONDUCTED IN AN
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
BROWN ACT PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
AND APA. THANK THANK YOU. NINE
ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES AND GOOD MORNING AS CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS CALIFORNIA
TAKING TANA- CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE EAST VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT- WE ARE CALLING TO-
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE AND ADMINISTRATION
ATTENTION TO A DROP FUNDING
PACKAGE AND WE ARE PARTICULARLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE ATTENTION TO
THE ISSUE OF THE WATER UTILITY
BILL OR MARRIAGES. AND ALSO TO
THE SENATE PACKAGES
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE SEPTIC
SYSTEMS CONTAMINATION ISSUE
THEY THINK MANY LARGELY
DISADVANTAGED AREAS OF THE
STATE WE URGE THAT SEPTIC TO
SEWER FUNDING IN THE ULTIMATE
PACKAGE BE SUBSTANTIAL AND
PACIFIC WE FOCUS ON THIS
PERVASIVE GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION ISSUE CONSISTENT
WITH THE RELEVANT LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY REFLECTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY BOND THEIR VEHICLE. AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS WERE NOT BE
ALARMING WITH NIELSEN MARKS
MORE ON BEHALF OF DAMPENING
ACCOUNTING ON ISSUE ONE FORTY
SIX WANT TO TELL MY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE KIANA VALENTINE WITH
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER SUPPORTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR STRATEGIC
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE.
AND ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS DEREK DOLPHY- HALF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
HAVE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER COMMENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN THE WILL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ARE SPEAKING TODAY ON ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE THE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY PACKAGE WE
APPRECIATE THE INCLUSION OF
PLANS INCLUDING THE MAY
REVISION TO HELP IMPLEMENT SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC
WASTE REGULATIONS BUT FEEL THAT
MORE FUNDING IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED. WE WANT TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE BUDGET
LETTER THAT WE IN A LARGE
COALITION STAKEHOLDER SIGN ON
TO ON MAY TWENTY FOURTH THAT
WOULD PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS DIRECTLY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SIMILAR TO
THE PROPOSAL CONTEMPLATED IN
THE SENATE AND INCREASING THE
FIFTY MILLIONDOLLARS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE MAYOR
VISION TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THESE DOLLARS TO REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS FROM LANDFILLS AND
HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS GET
THESE PROGRAMS UP AND RUNNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHECK MANY MEMBERS THE
SOCIAL PROPER SOUTH COAST
AGENCY THE SOUTH COAST INTO THE
NUMBERS CHALLENGES IN REDUCING
AIR POLLUTION AND TOPICS TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPRESSING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES SIGNIFICANT
SUSTAINABLE THAT THE FUNDING IS
CRITICAL FOR MANY HEALTH THINGS
FEDERAL AIR QUALITY STANDARDS-
SO MANY CRITICAL NEAR TERM
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. SOUTH OF
THE STATE INCLUDING FEDERAL
GUIDELINES REDUCE AIR POLLUTION
AN APARTMENT IN THE DARKENED
SANCTIONS RESTRICTIONS ON
BUSINESS AND IT'LL TAKE OVER
COULD OCCUR WE SUPPORT STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR FUNDING TO
REPLACE FUEL TRUCKS WITH NEAR
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS THAT ARE
LOWER COST AND START REDUCING
EMISSIONS IMMEDIATELY. MR
CONTENDED WITH ZERO EMISSION
OPTIONS BEING DEVELOPED FOR
MASS DEPLOYMENT IN THE FUTURE
WE SUPPORT AB AB OPTIMIZATION
SPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO THE
COLUMN WHERE PROGRAM NEXT
ACTION NOW PROVIDES PROGRAM
STABILITY PROBLEM POSTED
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN DEVELOPMENT
AND INSURANCE CARD INVESTMENT
IN CLEAN TECHNOLOGY. WE
APPRECIATE FUNDING FOR AIDS
RESEARCH FOR A BI SEVENTEEN
PHOTOS HOWEVER APPS THAT YOU
INCREASES FUNDING TO PRIORITIZE
NEAR TERM EMISSION REDUCTIONS
WE APPRECIATE YOU SUPPORTING
THE IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR
AIR DISTRICTS BUT AFTER YOU
INCREASES FUNDING TO COVER
ACTUAL. PROGRAM POPPED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR IS OPEN. GOOD
CAROLINE NUMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE FACING WITH THE WORLD
CAN WERE OF. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE THIRTY TWO
AND SAY THAT WE APPRECIATE THE
FUNDING FOR THE WILL OF
CONFLICT MANAGEMENT PROGRAM R.
C. R. C.'S IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THOSE PLANS AT SECOND WE'D LIKE
TO COMMENT ON THE ISSUE NINETY
TWO THE WILDFIRE MITIGATION
FUNDING PLAN AND JUST SAY THAT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARSWHICH IS IN
LINE WITH THE SENATE PROPOSAL.
HE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
YOU HOWEVER TO ADOPT THE SENATE
LONG TERM A FIVE YEAR FUNDING
PROPOSAL AT THE BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR AND WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER A
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM FOR
COUNTIES TO GET LOCAL FUNDING
ON THE GROUND MORE QUICKLY AND
FOR COUNTIES THEY CAN'T. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
AND AS STAFF TO- PROTECTED THE
PAINT AND- COMPETITIVE. GRANT
FUNDING PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS MARINA ESPINOSA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I'D
LIKE TO LINE MY COMMENTS WHAT
THE TESTIMONY FROM
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
GRANTS FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND LOCAL
BRICK REPAIR AND REPLACEMENT
PROJECTS AND OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS GETS
DECENT IMPROVEMENTS. TO BENEFIT
ALL ROAD USERS THE PROJECT
COULDADVANCE WITH ADDITIONAL
ONE TIME FUNDING THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CAN MEMBERS FOR YOUR WORK
ON THE BUDGET AFTER THE CREDIT
CRISIS THIS IS KILEY RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST FOR IT THREE
POINT TWO BILLION IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT DR
98% CALIFORNIA'S LEAD AND PLACE
IT BACK ON THAT'S GREAT FOR AIR
QUALITY THAT'S WHY WE URGE YOU
TO APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING FOR ONE
THOUSAND NEW CLEAN ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUSES TRUCKS IN TRANSIT
BUSES. OTHER THANK YOU FOR
WEAKENED BURKE THANK YOU WE ASK
YOU TO RECONSIDER RENEWING AB
EIGHT VEHICLE REGISTRATION FEES
SO WE CAN HAVE CONSISTENT
ONGOING FUNDING FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PLEASE INVEST IN
CLEAN AIR BY ALLOCATING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET TO SUPPORT CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS.
LIKE CLEAN CARDS FOR ALL. AND
THE CLEAN AT THIS PRO AND THAT
HALF OF THE INVESTMENTS AE
MADE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY'RE
NEEDED THE MOST. PLEASE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED NEARLY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENT. SO WE CAN
ACCELERATE TRANSITION TO ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. RENEWABLE
ENERGY INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWENTY MILLION. FOR
OFFSHORE WIND ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR TWENTY
MILLION PREDICT P. ECT CRANIAL
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES. TAX BUT I AUTOMATIC
SOLAR PERMITTING LIKE FULLER UP
TO REDUCE COSTS IN CLEAR
BACKLOG OF SOLAR PERMITS. WE
CAN POWER MORE HIGHLIGHTS. FROM
CLEAN SOLAR ENERGY THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. MY TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER
FOLLOW UP ON THE TOP OF THE
WATER ACTUALLY WATERFALLS
SENATE- ON A GENDER ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTY AND- THANKS FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION FOR MORE
VALUED ONE FROM. PEOPLE TO DO
WHAT ABOUT THE DRINKING WATER
WATER IN DROUGHT FROM I TRIED
SHE TRIPLE TO CHEER. HAKSTOL
ONE OF ONE. I DON'T. FIVE STUDY
OUT. ON THE- JOB ON THE
PARTICULARLY MUTUAL THAT SHOULD
BECAUSE THE WATER BACK- BE BACK
TO SEE WHAT- FOR. THAT TRUMP-
TO WHAT ABOUT TRAP BLACK TO
BURKE ON MARKET. OUR MOTION
ALTHOUGH JUST A PEOPLE CRITICAL
THAT IS WHY BURKE CHAU ELIGIBLE
VEHICLE ON HOW. YEAH A BLACK
BOX HEY. YOU LINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS FOR YOUR
MY COUNTY HOSPITAL AFTER TWO
VEHICLE CHARGING FUSION OF
COURSE OF COURSE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET TRAILER BILL
THE ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS FOR SEVENTY STRUCTURE
IN PARTICULAR THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF AB EIGHT ES
ALL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION TO SUPPORT TO SEE IF
HE'S CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. NOW IS THE TIME TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON BOTH VEHICLES
CENTERS ENCOURAGING
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE OUR
CLIMATE IN TRANSPORTATION GOALS
AS WELL TAKE A MULTI YEAR
APPROACH TO SHARE MARKET CHURCH
AND YOUTH. TO CONSUMERS AND
INDUSTRY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET TRAILER DOES
JUST THAT WE JUST MADE THE
REGARDING. OFFERS TRAILER BILL
ISN'T THE WRONG SIGNAL TO
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU. THANK AND
ONE TO NINE YOUR IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
MARGOT PARSONS THE WESTERN CAPE
CONTROLLING THE SITUATION
CALLING REGARDING THIS ITEM
THIRTY FIVE FIFTY THIRTY TO
THIRTY FOR OCTOBER I HAVE
WORKED VERY IMPORTANT A CRUCIAL
WORK THAT OFTEN DOES AND
BELIEVE THAT FULLY FUNDING THE
PROGRAM IS. EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT- HOWEVER WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT DELEGATION FEE
INCREASE ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND WHAT REQUEST THE
LEGISLATURE RETAIN THAT ABILITY
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
DEPARTMENT DEFINITE THAT WE
WOULD RECOMMEND USING GENERAL
FUND REVENUES TO ACT ALL THAT
GOOD THANK. YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS DON GILBERT
ON BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
AND RANCHO CALIFORNIA WATER
DISTRICTS IN REGARDS TO ISSUE
NINETY ONE DROUGHT RELEASE- WE
KNOW THAT NEGOTIATIONS WILL
ENSUE ON THESE MATTERS SHORTLY
WE JUST WANTED TO STATE THAT WE
SUPPORT THE SENATE PROPOSAL AS
THE BASIS FOR THE NEGOTIATIONS.
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON THE
RATE PAYERS- REEMERGES REALLY
PLAN IN THE SENATE PROPOSAL
WHICH IS VERY EFFICIENT AND
WILL GET THE MONEY TO ADDRESS
THE RATE PAYER DELINQUENCIES
QUICKLY WE ALSO WOULD LASTLY
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE WELCOME THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS IN THIS
AREA AND WE THINK SOME PORTIONS
OF HIS PROPOSALS WHICH THAT
NICELY IN THE SENATE. PROPOSAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING SIR PLAN A
NUMBER OF THE MANY FANS OUT OF
ON THE APPLE CHESLER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF ALLOCATING
TWENTY MILLION TO WORK ACT
PROVIDED FOR PERMITTING SUPPORT
FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR IN LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HI. MANY
STANDARDIZED SYSTEMS TECHNOLOGY
COULD STATE THAT BERG TOWARD
COMMUNITY GOING AND URGENTLY
NEED TO INCREASE TOWARDS HAPPY
TO KEEP SAFE DURING THE WILD
CARD WEEKEND THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TERRIBLE AND THEN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BRINGING IF YOU
WERE HERE A BUSINESS COUNCIL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUPLE
ALLIANCE AND THE FEAR OF
CONSORTIUM WE WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
WORKING ENSURING THAT THE QUICK
START BUDGET STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE RESILIENCE
IN THE FACE OF THAT TOLERATING
PRICE THAT. WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF MANY ASK OF BECOME PROPOSAL.
FUNDING FOR THE CLIMATE
CATHOLIC. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AND ISSUE
THIRTY SIX BE OUTDOORS FOR ALL
INITIATIVE. BEHIND THE PROPOSAL
LACKING IN ANY MEANINGFUL
FUNDING FOR THE LANDSCAPE SCALE
RESTORATION NEEDED MEET OUR
CLINICAL. THE SENATE QUITE IT
WAS ONLY PROPOSED FROM ALEX FOR
THE STATE CERVANTES AND WHILE
CON. BOARD AND ENCOURAGE
COOPERATION TO MEET THE FUNDING
AMOUNT. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NEED HELLO DELUCA IN
BEHALF OF THE OAKLAND TO THE
OAKLAND MUSEUM CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES AND THE
DISCOVERY SCIENCE CENTER.
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL YOUR TIME
AND OF COURSE THAT OUR STAFF
RIGHT NOW JUST WANT TO VOICE
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN THE ARTS
OR CULTURE AND CREATIVE SECTOR
AND THEN REALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR ASK. FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL AND HISTORICAL DOWN
MEANT THAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCIES OR INCREASE
EVERYONE'S TIME REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME THE STAFF
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. YEAH NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR
STUART WHY SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF MANY OF US WORKING HARD TO
STATE THE MONARCH BUTTERFLY
MIGRATION AND ALL POLLINATORS
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN. S.
DECIDES AND HABITAT DESTRUCTION
ARE DEVASTATING POLLINATORS AND
INSECTS SO WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S THIRTY MILLION
PER POLLINATOR HABITAT PROGRAM
IN THE NAY REVISED BUDGET
HOWEVER MORE IS NEEDED WE NEED
A DNA BARCODE DATABASE SO WE
CAN BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND THE
SCALE OF THE POLLINATOR.
PROBLEM MIGRATORY WESTERN
MONARCH BUTTERFLIES AT THE
CLIENT MORE THAN 99% OF THE
BELOVED MIGRATION WILL
DISAPPEAR UNLESS WE TAKE ACTION
TO RESCUE THEM JUST LIKE WE DID
CONTROVERSIAL BUT CUTER. ALSO
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HABITAT MEANS WE NEED TO
FINALLY ADDRESS PROBLEMS WITH
THE AVAILABILITY OF LOCAL
NATIVE SEAT SO WE ASK YOU TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR MONARCH
RESCUE AND STATEWIDE LOCAL SEED
BANK AS PART OF THE POLLINATOR
HABITAT. PROGRAM THANK YOU- YOU
ALTHOUGH THE CONDORS DON'T.
NINE ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH HI ANNONCES
MICROBES AND ON BEHALF OF THE
LITTLE EGG BURKE JOINT POWERS
AGENCY- CALLING ON IN SUPPORT
OF AT ISSUE FORTY FOUR ON PAGE
THIRTY TWO AND- AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE LABOR GPA IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S WATER
RESILIENCY PACKAGE
SPECIFICALLY. THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
FOR HABITAT AND HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR- FLOOD
PROTECTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. MY AND ONE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS JAMIE
MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE SIXTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
ALLOCATED PER ISSUE SEVENTY
NINE HEALTHY RESILIENT AND
EQUITABLE SYSTEM. LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT OUR SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE HEALTHY
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAMS.
THE PROPOSAL WILL HELP PROVIDE
ACCESS TO HEALTHY NUTRITIOUS
FOOD ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO FRESH
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE. BELIEVE
THAT BY INCREASING ACCESS TO
HEALTHY FOOD THE RISK OF DIET
RELATED DISEASES SUCH AS TYPE
TWO DIABETES HEART DISEASE AND
STROKE WILL BE DECREASED. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
THAT THAT THAT INVESTMENT. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NINE ONE FORTY
FIVE ELIZA'S OPEN. HI MY NAME'S
LANDRY PURCELL I'M CALLING WITH
FAMILIES ADVOCATING FOR
CHEMICAL AND TOXIC EIGHTY AND
ART AMERICANS RESPONSIBLE
TECHNOLOGY I WANT TO ADAM
CALLING REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S BROAD GRANT PROPOSAL
I WON AT THIRTY EIGHT ARE IN
FACT THE PREVIOUS COMMENT ON
BROADBAND WE URGE THE CARE BE
TAKEN TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
INVESTING IN WIRED. TO HAVE
WIRED FIBER TO THE PREMISES
WHICH MUNICIPALITIES CAN
IMPLEMENT AND REGULATE THE COST
OF ACCESS WITH WILL TRULY
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE AND
AVOID THE DANGERS OF FIRES
CAUSED BY WIRELESS ANTENNAS
WHICH OCCURRED IN MALIBU IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WIRED IS FASTER
SAFER MORE RELIABLE MORE SECURE
MORE ENERGY EFFICIENT DO NOT
SUPPORT THE MONOPOLIZATION BY
TELECOM CORPORATIONS WHICH WILL
PREVENT MUNICIPAL INTERNET AS A
PUBLIC UTILITY THANK. YOU THANK
YOU. AND LAST COMMENT IN QUEUE
LINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. HI I WANT TO GET MORE
INSURABLE REMEMBERS SHARE FOR
SOMETHING ELSE AND FOR
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL. C. H. FIFTY EIGHT MIN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
WHAT'S AN ISSUE AREAS NINETY
NINETY THREE NINETY NINE OF ONE
TEN ONE ELEVEN. THATPROMOTE
THE COMMERCIALIZATION OF
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN ACROSS
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION
SECTORS. BECAUSE THIS
INVESTMENT WILL BE REQUIRED AT
THE STATE ESTIMATED PROGRESSIVE
DECARBONISATION GOAL. THE
PROPOSAL BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
SCALING THE PRODUCTION OF
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WILL BRING
DOWN DECARBONISATION COSTS.
ACROSS THE TRANSPORTATION AND
ENERGY SECTORS PROVIDE ACCESS
TO FIRM DISPATCHABLE RENEWABLE
POWER. ENHANCE GRID RELIABILITY
AND RESILIENCY. UNPRECEDENTED
INVESTMENT IN MAJOR
DECARBONISATION PROJECTS LIKE
THE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
FOR LONG DURATION STORAGE
PROJECT ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION PROPOSED FOR THE GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE DERIVATION
VEHICLES AND REFUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE NECESSARY
AND FAMILY TO ME CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS. FINALLY THE
FIFTY FEET SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION OF FUNDS.
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE INCENTIVES AND CLEAN
CARDS FOR ALL PROGRAMS IS
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE TO HELP
STIMULATE THAT SALES INCLUDING
FUEL FELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
SALES. WILL CONTINUE TO BE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE STATE'S
DECARBONIZATION GOALS. THANK
YOU VERY TIME IN CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FOR
COMMENT IN CUBA THIS TIME. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR FOR. AT
ATTENDING TO ALL OF OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT TO AND ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO HAS. WORKED
MOVE THE BUDGET FORWARD BOTH
THE- HERE. IN THE HEARING AND-
BEHIND THE SCENES WE APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS. AND
WITHOUT THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.